Alex and Layla hermosi have become the
ultimate power couple together they made
over a hundred million dollars by their
early 30s and today they're sharing the
secrets behind creating a successful
relationship the single most important
decision that you make of all decisions
in life is who you spend your life with
building a multi-million dollar business
right now is pacing uh just about 250
million a year and how finding the right
partner could be the best or worst
Investments you will ever make yeah you
should learn how to do this like let's
build a [ __ ] business on this episode
of the ice coffee hour uh this episode
of subscribe thank you guys for tuning
in subscribe down below and let's get on
with the episode but first we gotta
thank our sponsor match oh boy now I've
known Jack for a while now and uh he's
perpetually single which I'm not
complaining about because that means he
has more time to work and although I
love focusing on myself I'm still a sad
lonely nobody and I'm a loser with no
friend Graham did you write this script
listen I've been working on myself
lately and it's honestly been amazing
for me and surprisingly it's something
that girls actually find kind of a try
active and now that I'm ready to get
back out there it's nice knowing that
being in a relationship actually might
save me some money match's latest study
of over 5 000 us singles reveals that
while the cost of being single is
skyrocketed in the last 10 years more
singles are looking to ditch the white
tablecloth and opt for freezy frail free
dates in fact over 30 of singles said
that they prefer to do a free activity
on the first date saving you money and
the busier things have gotten the less
I've been going out and meeting girls in
person how do you like the script Jack
it's the truth though it is the truth so
having the match app has allowed me to
maintain my busy schedule while also
allowing me to put myself out there and
just to prove that match has been my
favorite dating app recently I left my
profile link Down Below in the
description so for the audience
demographic that's like 15 that are
girls that are listening check it out so
having the match app has allowed me to
maintain my busy schedule while also
giving me time to put myself out there
to see what happens and the best
relationships show up when you show up
for yourself first and there's never a
better time to try out match so check it
out with that linked down below right in
time for the holidays so bring home
someone good for your parents maybe
it'll be me thank you so much match and
back to the podcast hello we are Alex
and Layla hermosi we run acquisition.com
which is private Equity Fund firm that
we just privately manage our own wealth
sounds really egregious when you put it
like that yeah oh yeah portfolio
companies does uh right now is pacing uh
just about 250 million a year it's been
a crazy Journey my wife and I
um met a long time ago and or actually
feels like it wasn't that long ago how
long ago was it seven seven years yeah
seven yeah but it's a lot has happened
since then so um yeah I'll give you the
quick we ride up to the present so I was
uh Consulting bro who like did really
well in school did the consulting job
did my two years was gonna go try and
get into Harvard you know scored really
well realized that I wanted to be an
entrepreneur in the two years of
business school and the cost Associated
like I couldn't pencil it out I was like
I could take that money and do two years
probably make the same money or more so
I decided to go that route I was 23 I
opened my first gym in California so I
drove across the country
um and opened gym because that's what I
thought I knew
um I didn't know anything but I thought
I knew a little bit about Fitness knew
nothing about business and that was a
rude awakening for me slept there on the
floor for the first nine months and then
was able to kind of figure it out as I
went I talked to gym owners every single
weekend I would fly out or drive out and
just like harass them to teach me more
about how to run the gyms learned a ton
and then from there every six months
after the first nine months I opened a
new location until we had six and uh
right around then is when uh Layla and I
met so I had I think five locations when
Leila and I met I had just spoken at an
event because they had heard that I
opened each of my gyms at full capacity
so marketing guy had heard about this
thing that I would do which I would I'd
run these big promotions and I'd
pre-sell the whole thing and I would use
the cash and the pre-sales to actually
pay for the the actual facility so I
never took cash out of pocket which is
why I was able to open them so fast and
um he's like dude you got to speak at my
event and tell how you did it so I spoke
at this event and after I got off stage
and like I was just hoping I wasn't
boring people and I got got mobbed like
I've never been still to this day I've
never been so like like people were in
the bathroom with me like I was like
this is this is a lot wait there what do
you mean they're in the back like I
could it took me an hour to get from the
stage to the bathroom so they were
following you into that they just want
to ask you a question about business or
like gym business or Fitness business
business in general but mostly Fitness
stuff because that's what I was like
here's how I'm getting you know 30 to
one back on I was like every dollar I
put in I get 30 back and here's the ads
and I just I didn't know how
presentations work so I was just like
this is what I do and they're like hey I
want to sign up for whatever your thing
is and I was like I don't have a thing
I'm just this is just what I do like
these are these are my numbers this and
they're like you have to have something
can I can I pay you for time because I
was like no I don't want to tell anybody
what I'm doing I just made this
presentation go away but I got like a
hundred like literally I had an Excel
sheet for to manage the 100 business
cards I got from just that speech
without wanting to
um and I met Layla I want to say like
that week I was like right after like
literally the week after yeah on Bumble
okay yeah on Bumble yeah so you could
probably pick it up from Bumble right
udmed yeah let the record show that's
house yeah what was your experience with
Bumble by the way I mean better than
Tinder yeah you know what I'm saying
what happened on Tinder
yeah I mean like it was just like
inundated with photos that I didn't want
to see and so I was like this is nasty
and Bumble was just coming onto the
scene then then I think like it was
fairly new still and like my girlfriends
that were like a little more classy told
me about it and I was like oh okay I'm
definitely gonna do that and so you know
I'm on Bumble and I'm ironically like I
am in California I had graduated college
and I had graduated with a degree in
exercise science and then the day after
I graduated I drove I like packed up my
Prius and I drove out to California and
I was like I'm gonna just I got like a
dumpy apartment that was like in the
ghetto of Costa Mesa I then was like I'm
gonna get a job at a gym so get a job at
a gym I applied to like literally every
gym I got accepted all them and like I
didn't even work at one of the nice ones
because in the beginning I was like okay
well when can I start making sales and
money and they're like you have to go
through three month training program and
I was like screw this like I need money
now because I don't have money to pay
for my apartment and so I did that and
then I worked my way up to being one of
the top sellers at the gym I was at I
then took my clientele went to a private
facility would train them there and then
started doing that plus online training
because that was like right at the
precipice of when online was like
starting so I was like you didn't need
to know how to do anything and you could
have people you know I was just like you
want to be my online client for 500 a
month like it was just like so easy 500
a month oh yeah you think that's a lot
yeah
it's just like you know they have an
online portal you're doing their what
what food they're supposed to be eating
you're giving them their workout regimen
or is that like videos like watching
them work out no oh it's just a schedule
wow yeah interests the program okay it
was so easy okay yeah so anyways you
know I'm doing that and I'm like I knew
that I wanted to have a business one day
I just didn't know what it looked like I
knew it was some kind of Fitness
business and
dating out in California was tough
because like I'm from the Midwest and
like I'm ambitious and I'm not I'm not
like a lot of the girls in California
where it's like you know I'd be like Oh
I'm single and they're like you should
be going on a date for breakfast lunch
and dinner and I was like girl what like
I'm working you know what I mean and so
I got on Bumble and I was like my goal
was every day at lunch I would swipe the
whole lunch and that was just like my
assignment to myself and so I did that
until I met Alex but now why did you
decide that that was the right time for
you to find somebody I didn't think it
was okay I just was like I one I have no
friends two all I do is work uh I need
to do like if I don't start now I'm like
how long is it gonna take me to find
somebody how old were you uh 23 and what
was the objective of doing that was it
to find like a lifelong partner or was
it just to like it was just honestly it
was just like somebody to have fun with
you know what I mean like it was like I
had no friends I didn't know anybody out
there I was like gosh like I I have to
try you know what I mean like find
somebody that would just be cool to hang
out with because I felt like a lot of
the guys I would meet like I literally
went on one day I'll tell you this I
meet this guy he's really cool we go on
this date you know I thought he was
awesome he like you know has good things
going for him he's like ambitious and
stuff and that was what I was looking
for specifically I want someone who's
ambitious who had like their own going
for them and the second date he takes me
to uh Javier's oh god oh it's very fancy
a very nice restaurant very nice place
with like a couple of his friends and I
think you know everyone was like
drinking a little bit I barely did at
that point and at the end of the dinner
we like saw sidelined afterwards and he
was like Hey and I was like yeah he's
like if you could just like not talk as
much that'd be great and I was like what
and he's like yeah I mean like you know
like you look really nice and like if
you were just like you know I want you
to come to the dinner and like sit and
like look nice and I was like oh oh we
are not one in the same and I was like
this is not gonna as bluntly as that
yeah and that was like mackerel that
sums up my dating experience in Newport
Beach California was like why can't you
just shut the [ __ ] up and look pretty
trophy was that's what everybody wanted
okay and I've just never been that
person you know I mean like when I moved
there everyone's like I'm trying to get
clients for example and they'd be like
hike up your shorts pull down your shirt
and I was like what the I was like I
will win off being so good at business
not off of showing off skin right and
that's just always who I've been so that
was my experience up until Alex was just
a lot of that and then I was like all
skin yeah hold it down yeah
yeah I got a question so were you guys
paying for Bumble premium like the the
advanced I don't think that exists
I remember it it just like started
really I didn't because I was need
unlimited unlimited looks I was like
I'll play I'll play on steroids I'll
play Nash I'll go yeah yeah and and you
were not paying for it as well no
interesting okay so you guys know Andre
Jack right yeah Andre yeah the finance
YouTuber he basically came to me and
he's like hey man I know you don't pay
for apps because I have you know I got
them all and he said but you should it's
a numbers game and if you just swipe and
swipe and swipe you have a higher chance
of finding a right match and they also
show you who likes you if you pay for
Tinder Platinum which saves you copious
amounts of time right and it's worth it
if you average out your you know the
value of your time and the time spent on
the apps if you don't have it it's worth
it
we're just both cheap I think yeah I was
super cheap back then so like okay I
just don't think I was like fair enough
do you remember swiping on Alex's
profile
let's set that apart
well
it was a picture of a guy with a
six-pack oh my God no that was the
that's like really that was the water
yeah in the water with sunglasses on it
was it was it was not like in the mirror
I was like at the beach okay literally
in the water half so someone else took
the face I was like I was I've had some
floaty or whatever that I was like
moving and some just had to like can you
tell us was that it was an old picture
okay which I've realized when we met
yeah so that was who it was but it
specifically it was like Fitness and
business so it was like own five gems
Fitness and then like something else you
you remember expensive steaks cheap
bourbon some expenses takes can get
behind that yeah but I was like oh
business and fitness like that sounds
like me too so that was why I swiped
yeah and then he messaged me immediately
after I messaged him and was like we
should get off the app let's talk on the
phone and that was actually what I
appreciated the most is I was like I'm
so sick of these guys that have like so
much time to waste you know like talking
on these apps not actually like moving
forward to a date I was like this is
just like lame so I actually really
appreciate that he wanted to talk on the
phone but first we got to thank our
sponsor Ridge wallets I don't know about
you guys but I've had way too many
wallets to count and every time I get a
new wallet it ends up getting really
bulky and the leather starts wearing out
that's why I'm really happy that Ridge
wallets reached out and sent us some of
their wallets Rich wallets are the
Perfect combo of sleek yet durable I've
been using a wallet they sent me and I
love how easily it fits in my pocket and
how good it looks they've also sent a
key case which I've really wanted and
it's easy to use and that helps me not
look like a janitor everywhere I go plus
as most of you know I have a lot of
credit cards my biggest concern was
being able to use all of them and fit
them in a wallet that's as Sleek as this
and not have it just completely break
but I was pretty surprised the ridge
wallet actually fits up to 12 cards
which hey there's more than enough it's
also made with RFID blocking technology
so it protects you from digital
pickpocketers and guys the ridge team is
so confident that you'll like their
product that they'll let you test drive
it for 45 days there's literally no risk
you could send it back for a full refund
if you're not 100 satisfied but trust me
I never knew I needed a nicer wallet
until I got one and now I can't live
without it so like I said I've been
using the ridge wallet for about three
or so weeks now and I can't emphasize
enough how much I absolutely love it
strongly recommend you guys check them
out with that link down below there's
also over 30 styles and colors including
carbon fiber which is what I got and
burnt titanium so get the best offer
right now with the link ridge.com coffee
and you can save up to 40 through
December 22nd thank you so much Ridge
and back to the podcast because I
started on Tinder and I was like oh I do
not want to be on here
um I went on one date without like
talking to the girl first just like via
message or whatever and it was like the
weirdest date of my entire life and I
was like would you I would pay you to
leave can you please anyways well wait
can you tell us what went wrong with it
oh God it was so I unders this was the
first date I went on after being in five
relationship there were no apps like I I
didn't know any of how this world worked
so I had texted with this girl or
whatever and I was like hey uh I live in
this I lived in a really nice condo
um I was like oh there's like this whole
pool thingy area like we can meet at my
place and then we'll like go hang out
there Grill whatever middle of the day
so I wasn't trying to be you know
sketchy or whatever I now realize that
it is incredibly sketchy for a girl to
just meet a guy at his place on the
first date without a conversation right
so like that's who I was dealing with
here so she just shows up at my door
we sh I let her in and I still only
think about this in retrospect and we
have probably the most awkward no like
weird exchange like I don't know what to
talk to you about anything and then this
is maybe like a 45 or 60 Minute date and
and then she was like hey do you have
any food and I was like
yeah I've got like leftovers and she was
like I was like do you want food and she
was like yeah that'd be great she was
like I've got I got to go up to LA
tonight for dinner and I was like and
then it like became clear was another
date and so I was like okay so I'm lunch
got it all right so I know it was
another date didn't it have been like
friends you know what I mean like I'm
guessing she also was hungry in a
different way and that's why she was
there to eat lunch so anyways I like
literally heated up leftovers I gave her
a plate she ate it like she was hungry
she ate the whole plate and then I was
like
buy you know like did she not leave you
a tip I mean I feel like yeah it's a
gratuity of some sort
that was my first online dating exchange
and I was like this process is broken
how did you kick her out I was like she
finished yeah she finished and then left
right and so I was gonna finish your
plate
um
that taught me a really important lesson
which is I was like no more dates
without a phone screen and so
um I would get on and within two
messages I would say hey I have lunch at
this time I can call you at that time
while I'm on my way like what's your
number and four out of five times the
girls be like thank God like I don't
want to talk on these apps all day and
then one out of five times it would be a
ghost so that was my like my metric
there and so I would get on the phone
and I would just do a phone screen so I
was just like hey you know how's it
going what's going on whatever whatever
and so what happened though and I think
reason my like close rate was higher was
that I would go to the date with like a
first date out of the way so we'd have
like a 15 or 20 minute call and so I'd
be like oh yeah right because your
brother he's in Iowa and he's a medical
engineer yeah totally and so if there
was just more Rapport and more like
feeling of familiarity and so anyways
um that became a Mainstay in the process
and I would always do Froyo for the
first date if I could to have a low
commitment so we can back out in like
five or ten minutes if it's like not
good and so that was um anyways that was
my that was my bundle dating I have a
funny Tinder story I think I've told you
this one Jack but I was trying to
optimize for Tinder yeah and I noticed
that may maybe I'd only get a few
matches a day and gosh this must have
been like 10 years ago I was swiping and
all of a sudden I see like this blue
like this glowing blue profile oh yeah
I'm like what it's what is this and it's
a super like yeah and so I screenshotted
it and I photoshopped my main picture to
be a super like because I think you're
only around unlimited super likes on
every single girl every every single one
and I went from getting maybe a few
matches a day to hundreds no and it
lasted about three to three weeks and
then my profile was taken down oh you
got banned I got that that's smart
though it works brilliant that's so good
um yeah so that's so we actually did uh
we did Froyo for the first date true to
the true to the process you know stick
to the process very romantic yeah and I
actually so Layla actually got there
first
um and I was walking up from behind her
and uh I immediately was like [ __ ]
because she has a full back tap
um like back to to back to tailbone and
I was like no this is not going to be a
good date
um so like he walks up were you wearing
an open back yeah yeah I didn't even
think about it though because like I got
this thing you know 10 years ago
whatever it was I got so long ago and I
was like when I was high and like it is
what it is but um he walks up and back
and then he comes in the front and like
he's just like hey
and I was like
oh God
I was like and he was like you want to
go in get some Pro I was like I was like
let's knock this out I was like half
smiling like yeah you know like hey you
know and and we go in and we're standing
in line I remember just looking at his
face he was like I don't think we talked
they didn't talk I'm dead serious I
think I don't think we talked how do you
have that confidence to not feel like
you need to like you know be energetic
in a date you know I think it's Supply
demand
you really yeah so as long as you go on
so many dates it just doesn't you no
longer follow that antsiness and like
but didn't get a lot of that out in the
phone call in the phone screening
process there was definitely yeah the
phone screen went and actually Layla
tried to cancel on the date
she did
but I I told him I was sick and he goes
you're not sick how do you know how did
you know I was just like I've been
selling for a long time you know what I
mean I was like what gave it away I
could just she didn't have conviction in
her and her and she's like oh well I'm
kind of sick I was like you're on the
phone with me I was like oh that's sick
I was like I was like no I really don't
feel good he's like yeah you're fine
we're going on the date tomorrow and I
was like what
holy cow that's a power move right there
I kind of appreciated it because you
don't imagine nobody ever pushes back on
me
did you feel the need to say you were
sick like what made you hesitant about
that yeah I think I was hungover because
I went out and partied the night before
God so you weren't feeling well then and
I was like oh I just don't want to you
know okay this like what do I care I was
and like listen I've had so many bad
dates at this point like I'm pretty sure
the one right before that the guy like
tried to sneak me into a movie without
paying like it was just like it was bad
he tried to sneak because he wanted to
save the like you want to save money and
how did did he end up doing it
successfully we got we went in I was
like wait don't we have to he's like no
I have this special uh paths and I was
like okay and you got it and so we went
in and then the security came up to us
no and they were like you need to leave
you snuck into the movie so I was like
wait did you he's like oh I was just
trying to save a few dollars
man like it was just like movie First
Date yeah I don't know part of me
thought that Alex might be like a little
bit of a sociopath when I talked to him
so I was like I don't know like the way
he's talking and everything like it
sounds a little sketchy yeah so that was
honestly like my inkling as well and
then you know turned out to be true so
yeah there you go so what happened with
the tattoos you're in line and you're
not saying anything so no I mean yeah we
weren't saying anything and then I also
tend to be a little bit of a hangry
person so like if I don't eat for a
while
um I'm not as friendly
um and so I got so I you know I started
a couple bites Froyo got a little sugar
in my system and I was like all right
tell me about you what's going and then
you know it it warmed up okay and then
and then we had a great conversation
because she wanted to talk about
business and so I was like great and
because
the vast majority of my dates was always
just like me spending a lot of energy
pretending to be interested in whatever
they were saying
um and I was like I don't have to
pretend to be interested in what you're
saying this is great we're gonna talk
about what I want to talk about which is
business so I'll talk all day and so we
talked for like four hours we like went
on a walk for like we went walk like two
something miles like just talking and
which I had also read was a way of
increasing trust faster because people
trust inherently people they travel with
he told me that while we were walking oh
he's like listen what I'm doing to you
right it's like I'm increasing Rapport
faster that's like let's go for a walk
and was there certain like aha moment
where you were on the date and you're
like okay this is good you check all the
boxes and we're good to go there had to
have been for you because you came to my
car right after yeah yeah so we I had to
go to a dinner
um just a friend's dinner and uh I was
like hey I actually need to
buy steak and stuff for this dinner I'm
gonna go so I was like want to grocery
shop with me for like 30 minutes because
we were like in a retail shopping yeah I
got it she was like okay and so then we
shopped for like the last 30 minutes or
what 20 minutes whatever it was to to
get the steaks and then I was like hey
this was fun let's do this again and
then he called me that night yeah and
then we talked for like three hours
three hours yeah and then after that the
thing the thing that made this
religiousness yeah you're talking about
just all business and honestly we talked
about a lot of stuff from the very
beginning like views on everything in
life essentially you know what I mean
like just perspective yeah yeah okay 100
was there anything romantic at that
point or it was mostly just like hey we
hit it up you're smiling and you're
shaking your head I was thinking about
in the pool do you remember what I said
oh yeah yeah yeah no there was not
romantic Vibes in the beginning which is
like weird because like we're like
physically a very compatible match and
everything but like I think we were just
like for me at least I was like it's
just so nice to talk to someone that I
actually want to talk to like I was like
I want to keep talking to this person
I'm just so interested that was the word
it was like I'm so interested did more
interested than I am concerned with like
anything else yeah yeah and what was it
that you said in the pool
ah so it was our second date yeah it was
our second right
um and we were in the pool and I was
just surprised because I think by then
we'd gone on to this is our second date
and he didn't try to kiss me on the
first date and then we're on the second
date and we're like in the pool playing
around I'm in a bikini and he didn't try
and kiss me or anything and I was like I
don't understand
so I literally looked at him and I was
like I I just feel like I just kind of
get just friend Vibes and he was like he
had never seen all of a sudden his face
turned from like super friendly to like
you're gonna learn and he was like
friend and then he like threw his head
back and Chuckles and he was like I'll
show you you know like oh my God it was
I said that trigger point is to be a
friend oh no never it was so fun yeah
not once in my entire life had a girl
said I get friend vibes from you ever
like ever and so to me it was like this
is the funniest like I I laugh like a
psychopath when I heard that so I was
like that is the funniest thing he
wouldn't stop laughing and I was like
and then I got kind of scared I was like
I don't know what I said wrong
yeah and so uh yeah the resolution yeah
we resolved that we were not friends uh
you know that was that was he kissed me
made my intentions good nice
um but yeah but I mean the I think that
the thing that was interesting for me at
least was that the word that she used
interested was the same one that I had I
was like she's just interesting like I I
enjoyed talking to her I wanted to keep
talking to her
um and I didn't feel like there was a
lot of effort on my part to like keep
conversation go or anything like that
and so
um what pretty much after that first
date we hung out every day and so it was
much more like uh
and we didn't go on dates I was just
like I'm gonna be working all day you
can work next to me if you want and she
was like sure and so that was what we
did and so we pretty much just like
started living life together like as
soon as we as soon as we met and there
wasn't a lot of like relationship stake
because within the first week of us of
us being together I was like you should
you should quit your thing and work with
me like even if I remember saying I was
like even if this doesn't work out or
like I don't come with the deal like
this is employment this is what I would
pay and it'll be whatever your pay
getting paid because I know like if you
can sell like we can make a ton of money
together and that so I was not receptive
at first yeah she was not receptive why
is that but we just we just met I mean
you know that wasn't into it it's all
your eggs
and career yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah and
you know he pointed out that like
everyone's he you know the options that
I had were like people trying to
basically like monetize me yeah and he's
like you're bringing everything to table
and then he's like but come work with me
and I was like well he's like like yeah
but you're making way more money so it
took like a few weeks yeah okay I mean
and that was where I was like I have
this new idea and that's because I just
spoken at that event to go full circle
so I just spoken at that event I had all
these business cards and I was like I
think I could make some money doing this
like just figuring out how to like help
other people like launch their gyms and
so I um I was like I'm gonna start this
thing called gym launch and uh like the
next time she came over like I had all
the docs and the bank accounts and
everything like it was all set up and
she was like like you're gonna do it I
was like yes I was gonna do it like
let's go do it but she still wasn't like
sure because she had a full book of
business it takes like a year or two
years sometimes to build up a full like
training roster and so she already had
that so it would be like significant
cost or risk to walk away from that and
so I was like well I'm gonna go do this
and I'll come back and let you know how
it goes and so I called every night
while I was doing these launches and so
I did three launches in like I want to
say like six weeks something like that
it's like two and a half weeks it was
definitely longer than that was that I
was at Josh's for two and a half weeks
and I did three launches so I feel like
it was two weeks it was like six weeks
and so and then I flew back
and she picked me up from the airport
and she was like you have to take me on
a date that's the because I hadn't taken
her date I'm like I was like I need to
set some standards here which is like
you know we've been going to Panda
Express and chipotle every night and
like as nice as tomorrow I was like we
should go do something that's like cute
and fun you know
where did you guys go on the date The
Cliff in Laguna Beach okay and as she
picked me up I was like hey I know I
promised you were on a date I did this
one thing first and she was like dude
seriously she was like dressed up ready
to go and I was like just so I poured
her a glass of like whiskey or something
and then I ordered myself one and I
taught her how to process payments and
so I took out this fat sack of contracts
and I was like can you just help me
process all these and so we processed
like 45 minutes later we had processed
like 120 Grand or something like that
um in an hour and uh I knew what I was
doing and so I was like so like you want
to do this thing with me and uh who the
first question she asked me was is this
legal
I didn't know you know you also have to
understand context which is like Alex's
apartment at the time for example like
you walk in it's like pristine clean
with like pictures of animals and
killing positions on the walls and then
like in the fridge it's just like Diet
Coke and yogurt and he drinks egg whites
out of a carton while he's drinking
whiskey like you know I'm like
questionable what taught you that was a
normal way of like life well I didn't it
was a normal way of life but I didn't
want a normal life I knew it well I mean
I had I had Coke Zero I had Red Bull I
had uh Greek yogurt that was zero
percent and I had egg whites and then I
had uh Johnny Walker Black
is Coke Zero that unhealthy because I've
been getting into Diet Coke lately and I
hear like a lot of people tell me like
it has what do they call carcinogens and
how smart are those people sorry I don't
know that's the thing you know I know
nothing about nutrition so anybody's
probably let's blow up the comments it's
fine it's fine it's better at a week and
it wouldn't be unhealthy for you sure
really you drink water all day great
yeah it's also better to like not drive
in cars only walk everywhere like don't
smoke don't see people like live in a
bubble your whole life you're facing the
dirt every morning not live but if
drinking a Coke Zero is the thing that
you're like most concerned about in your
life and you're doing everything else
which is a big obvious stuff like the
people who are upset about like Diet
Coke and cokes here are the ones that
like don't even work out I'm like dude
why don't you just like shut the [ __ ]
you're a very clean person just in
general I'm neat I'm very I'm like I'm
tidy I don't like stuff out well you
pick up after me so now it's like you
don't have to be yeah you know like with
myself like I I would I would spend a
very a lot of effort to not make a mess
I wouldn't have to claim so I would like
eat over the sink the same cup you know
that's what I did yeah
yeah one fork one spoon One Bowl that's
it they just wash it as soon as they're
done simple life yeah it worked out fine
and I would always just put water on it
and as soon as I would as soon as I
would eat the next meal I would just
because it was like yeah easy exactly
one wipe and then that's funny the exact
same thing dude it works fine and then I
had all the the animal pictures on the
wall of like and killing and attack
positions because like I was really
hardcore at the time like
more than I am now
um and I was just like I always want to
be reminded that I'm either the predator
of the prey I was pretty good I can't
even he told me that it's nominating
doesn't that make you feel like the prey
now
I was like well I'm not the best no I
just couldn't even take it seriously I
was like I remember he told me and I
started laughing and he was like what
and I was like what you know like I just
I don't know I thought it was quirky
yeah it was definitely quirky but I was
like it wasn't for her you know what I
mean it was for me and so for me it was
like
if I didn't want to work or whatever I
would just like everything around me was
like keep going you know what I mean and
that was the stage I was in
business-wise like I was very much in
the like I have to I have to grind I
have to work a lot uh phase and so I
just and that's why it worked out with
us because I I didn't the biggest thing
that biggest reason I believe that our
among the biggest reasons is that Layla
never tried to change me and that was
something that I felt like was a
constant in the majority of the other
relationships that I had was like you're
here I'm here let's meet in the middle
and that's why I have such strong
stances on compromise because I like I
don't think you can compromise on you
you know what I mean and so I always
felt like I had to be less than or a
different version of myself in order to
like make the relationship work and um I
also was in a season where like I just
gotten out of a long relationship so I
was like I'm not really bending the knee
to anyone for anything like I'm not
compromising if you don't like my
schedule then cool like I'm not gonna
stop living how I live
and so she just kind of like
oriented herself around me and it worked
just amazingly well and I got to do what
I want to do all day which is work and
it was great how did you feel about that
did you feel like you needed to
compromise or or bend a little bit to
fit Alex or what was your side of things
on that no honestly I think we got
really lucky because I was kind of
always the same way which is like I'm
not gonna like be less of myself and
like less ambitious and less career
oriented for a man because that was what
typically they wanted of me so I
actually really like the fact that he
wanted to work all the time because I
was just finally somebody that didn't
tell me like oh you need to go do your
hair and look pretty like it was someone
who's like yeah you should learn how to
do this like let's build a [ __ ]
business like let's do all this stuff
like I just love that
he believed in me so much and I think
most men that I had dated at that point
sure I'm sure they believed in me but I
don't think that they wanted me to ever
be any better than I was because they
were worried that it would be better
than them where do you think that
Independence came from have you always
been like that was it an upbringing was
it a I think it was a couple things yeah
uh one you know like having one of my
parents separated
um and I lived with my mother she
basically was an absent parent uh just
you know alcohol and all that stuff and
so
for a period of time it was kind of like
I raised myself like nobody was there
kind of have to learn how to do things
for yourself for context because Layla
won't say it like Layla would be alone
for days or weeks at a time that's like
a nine-year-old like a different vibe
you know what I mean just for context
here yeah yeah
um but either way I think it was that
plus then when I finally moved in with
my dad when they figured out like that
my mom was not fit to be a parent
um my dad he's always just instilled
like a huge sense of like you need to
have your own career you need to make
your own money like you need to be
self-sufficient as a woman
um and he's always very adamant about
that for me and my sister so I think it
was hearing that as I'm growing up like
that is the priority I think but a lot
of women here is the priority is like
you're gonna have a family and you're
gonna have kids and like that's what you
do versus like my dad was like you make
money you have a living of your own you
have a career like that's what you do
and so if you're told that enough times
I think that becomes kind of your frame
of the world
I remember I think it was either the
first or second time we had U1 you said
that there are two different you know
relationship structures that work well
and one is like we're in the trenches
together we're grinding it out the other
one is the cheerleader and the football
player right and what is your sentiment
towards this you said that we're in the
trenches together is more powerful it's
harder to break and it's just a better
overall relationship is kind of what you
were hinting at divorce rates for people
who have made a dollar together in a
business they started
um is 10 so it's significantly lower and
I think maybe that's because there's
like in order to even get to that first
dollar together with somebody like
there's a lot of other things that have
to be aligned and then you also have
this post commitment kind of bias where
you both want to keep this thing alive
and you're both working together towards
like a shared Mission or goal and so I
think there's just a lot of alignment
that happens there and there's also a
lot of um context and so one of the
things that I think happens in many
relationships is that people get exposed
to different stimuli and then they adapt
to the stimuli and then they grow apart
just because of the nature of just
stimulus response right and so if you're
you're both in the same business
together you're being exposed to the
same stressors and then you you can grow
together in the same direction and I
think at least for us that's been our
experience rather than having to like we
just have a shared Mission and so we're
on it together I think it's um something
we were talking about the other day is
you know we were talking to a guy and he
was talking about wanting an open
relationship and I come from the air of
like I'm not the kind of woman who's
like oh my husband should never look he
never looks at another woman I assume
that Alex looks at other women because
he's a man like that is what men do and
that's like how we're wired like we're
humans right that's a human thing and I
think what I subscribe to is that if you
want a relationship to last then you
have to create more reasons to stay with
the person than to not because there's
always reasons not to be with somebody
Freedom autonomy you want to go bang
other people whatever it is right it's
like we have all these human instinctual
things that are pulling us in One
Direction can you create more reasons
within your relationship to stay with
that person so if you work together if
you're on the same Mission together if
you have the same values if you both
like Fitness and Nutri and like all
these things those are all the arguments
as to why you want to be with that
person and I think what happens a lot of
relationships they just don't have much
of an argument it's like cool we like
each other and that's it like I can go
[ __ ] 10 other people and then there's
nothing else in common they're not on
the same Mission they have nothing else
to argue so when things are hard your
mind is going to go why am I with this
person it's like I have a million
reasons why I'm with Alex if we ever
have a hard day it's like it that the
thought of exiting doesn't even cross my
mind because there's so much
overwhelming evidence as to why it makes
sense to stay don't you think it
complicates things to also be in
business that maybe not financially you
have an incentive to stay together I
think I mean absolutely complicates
things in terms of like there are more
there are more layers to the
relationship but I also think that to
the same degree they can compound and
become
even you become even you have more
potential for disruption but also more
more potential for alignment so I'll say
something yes which is like me and Alex
when we are dating we broke up for six
weeks
um and we we talked about in the very
beginning of our relationship like if
we're gonna get into business together
and do this together then we need to
know what it would look like if we
weren't together and so when we broke up
we both uphold our end of the bargain
like we were great Partners to each
other without being in a relationship
and so like I look at it like this which
is like if you have to worry about the
exit then you shouldn't be with the
person I don't worry about that with
Alex and I I even we talked about this
the other day I was like it would we
would just do that again you know what I
mean like it would be amicable and so I
think if you have to worry about what it
would look like oh we're gonna fight
over money and do stuff it's like then
don't be with the person why did you
guys break up was that on purpose it was
it was mostly me yeah
we should test pick you know let's see
what it's like see how it goes
I had so at the time this is like this
was probably like during the hardest
90 to 120 days of probably my like
career besides going out on my own and
like starting the gym like that was very
hard for me but this was like the next
hardest season because like I had lost
all the money because of a partnership
that person had taken the money out of
the account it was the whole thing so
I'd lost basically all the money I'd had
from
opening and scaling all the gems so like
when I met her I felt like I had high
status because I had five gyms and I was
successful I was doing these things and
then I lost everything
and then my mom got in an accident and
then so she was at the hospital and then
I got a DUI and a head-on collision
um all within a matter of like a month
and a half yeah and I just like and I S
and I still had a partnership for a
chiropractor agency a partnership for a
dental marketing agency I was doing the
actual launches flying out not at home
doing these launches and then I still
had my five gyms at home and so I was so
spread thin and I had so much emotional
noise that was going on that I was like
she actually came to me she almost like
broke up with herself she was like
do you want to not do this and I was
like yeah that's fine that was literally
the conversation I was like do you want
to just not do this and he was like yeah
and I was like okay how long into the
relationship was this well we were
living and traveling together at this
point we were in in Virginia we were in
a different state launching a gym there
together
and uh seven months in yeah somewhere in
there seven no how do you feel like a
relationship complicated things for you
at that time versus just being a
business partner was it
it's just time it was no it's just like
there's another Dynamic you know if we
were just business partners there's not
like another Dynamic of the relationship
you have to take care of you know what I
mean and what was that like for you
going through all of those within a
month and a half how did you come out of
that better I mean I just I honestly I
did not have attention that's all like
so that was what I identified was that I
was just way too spread thin and so I
I mean I say this a lot but like a lot
of times like the life you want is on
the other side I have a few hard
conversations and so I knew I shouldn't
have been in those Partnerships like
multiple of them I was still in the
partnership with the guy who had taken
all the money you know what I mean like
I was so afraid of Confrontation and so
I was like we need to end this
and I was in another partnership and I
was like I need to end that and then I
was on it I was in three different
Partnerships across those different
companies and I ended all of them and
the difficulty for I knew it was going
to be a hard conversation because I was
the one who was for the I mean I was
there was I was the one who was bringing
the money in and so it didn't didn't
change my life but I knew it was going
to change theirs if I left the dynamic
of the relationship yeah and so um
that's why I was dreading those
conversations and and so anyways I had
all those conversations I you know cut
back on my drinking significantly and
then just try to like focus on the thing
that was in front of me which was like
this was actually Layla she was like
dude the gym watch thing works like we
should just like focus on that and uh I
was like all right let's do that and so
I lost all the money and then Layla went
to launch this big gym in Hawaii and
this and it ended up being and so
one of the reasons that we got back
together was that I never could rely on
anyone and so it was like it was always
Alex has to save the game right and I
was accustomed to doing that I'd done
over and over again in the business
whatever
and so when she flew out to Hawaii I
basically was like you need to make this
work like you have to crush this launch
and I didn't have that much money left
and it cost 10 grand to like put her up
in Hawaii for it was like six weeks or
whatever like hotels airfare in Hawaii
is expensive and so she was splitting a
house with five guys and it was still
like 250 a night
um but it was all I could like really
afford and so we launched this gym in
Hawaii and then in that time she set the
all-time record for sales and so it was
like at a time that was probably pretty
difficult for her you know what I mean
like we had just broken up what's my
future look like what am I going to do
with this guy you know whatever and
she's in another state in the middle of
the ocean
um and I was like you have to come
through and she did and so it was one of
those times where like
most people
had always wilted Under Pressure but
like Layla was hard as [ __ ] and I was
like man wherever I'm going I know that
I need someone like that with me because
I know where I want to go and the life
that I want to lead is not going to be
normal and so I need somebody who can
handle that kind of pressure and she
crushed it and so we talked every night
while we I mean just like we weren't
like malicious we talked every night
still about the business things that we
were improving et cetera and she came
back and that cash was what I was able
to put into all the refunds at this gym
that I basically had to shut down that
was my number six that that other guy
was supposed to partner with me and then
he dipped or whatever so I had to put I
basically had a float payroll rent
everything without bringing you new
sales basically just out of my savings
which sucked
um and so all that cash went to there
and so that was that was when she came
back I was I was in a better place I'd
like cleaned up a lot of these like hard
conversations I needed to have and she
had just like stood tall throughout the
whole time and so I think what happened
at that point is that Layla earned my
respect and so like not that I didn't
respect her before but like she had
earned the respect like independent you
know what I mean it wasn't like oh yeah
we're gonna do this thing together and
you're a girl that I'm with it was like
I would do this with you even if we
weren't together yeah and I think that
was the pivot what kept you going Layla
through that like what what motivated
you at that point to work so hard I
think I've always worked really hard and
so it was just like
I kind of like the moments when it's
like you either like it's an inflection
point right where it's like I could give
up and I know what my life might look
like I'll go back home I've got to go
pick up training again I've got to go do
all this stuff or I can [ __ ] like
pull some strength out of myself and
like crush it here and I think that I
was looking for an opportunity to show
him what I was capable of because I
think also like Alex didn't trust me
fully I think to that extent yet like in
terms of like decisions you know like my
input nothing at that point and I felt
like I want to show him like I'm really
[ __ ] capable and I remember thinking
that to myself like he doesn't
understand like I'm not I get it like I
can do this and I think I looked at it
as like I want to show him what I'm
really made of and so it worked yeah and
then and if I didn't then I would have
still made a lot of money so it's fine
sure yes I mean when she came back I
think the dynamic of the relationship
was just it was different it was better
it was just like all right like game
recognized game like all right what do
you think about this you know so it was
much more like before that it was very
much like this is what we're gonna do
this is the plan and after that I
started being like what do you think
about this this is where I'm this is
where I'm at like me or two cents and so
then and then it became much more of a
partnership so that was a big aha moment
basically that one was yeah whatever
happened to the guy who stole the money
were there any red flags that led up how
much money so many red flags yeah can
you say oh I mean so I'll tell you what
what I knew what I what I was told which
was that I you know I confronted was
like Hey man like you just drained the
bank account which is where I put all my
savings to start this new thing together
and so he had said hey like well I'll
give the 60 Second Story was I was
launching all these gyms we were filling
them up and he was like dude you're
leaving all this money on the table and
me being the distracted entrepreneur
that I was I was like yeah I'm leaving
all this money on the table I should be
owning all these gyms that I'm launching
he's like dude you launch a new gym
every month and I'll just come behind
you and I'll I'll staff it up and run it
and that way and we'll just split it 50
50. I was like cool I don't want to run
them like I'll just keep launching them
and open it so that was the deal
um but what ended up happening so I
launched this gym we murder the launch
um like 370 something people signed up
which is really big for like a gym
launch
and uh and I was like all right man like
you ready to run the thing he's like oh
no I've got my location you handled that
one and I was like whoa no no no no no
no no like I already had my five
locations like this is not my game
anymore I'm not running gyms anymore
like I already I've graduated from that
like I'm not doing this
um and so we had some stickiness and
then I woke up one day and all the money
from that gym that I'd done 300 plus and
each one of those is like six you know
five six hundred dollars uh times 370 so
there's a good amount of money in the
account plus the money that I put in to
like open it get things going Etc
um
it was all like gone and uh I was like
dude with that he's like I know you've
been skimming I was like
what
he's like I'm just taking my half
he's like because I know you like you
have already taken out the other half I
was like dude I no I haven't I haven't
and so I went to a coach and the coach
was like just show him the math he's
like just print out the bank statements
and go line by line I was like okay so I
printed out the bank statements and I
went line by line and highlighted
everything and I was like hey let's meet
up
um and he was like oh I don't want to
see that and as soon as he didn't want
to look at the math that's when I knew
that I had been played and so at that
point and the crazy part is like were
there red flags he'd already been
indicted for fraud I already knew this
and he was like it was a
misunderstanding and I believed him and
that's one of those like you know the
the the the
saying uh when experience meets money
and money meets experience seeing the
experience gets the money and the money
against the experience that was very
much my I got the experience so lesson
learned but the thing that like I would
say as a as a kudos for Layla is that
Layla has like
Layla's people picker is
it's dead on like I since we've been
together like in a lot of the reasons
that my you know
my business has grown
since meeting Layla versus before is
that she's such a good judge of
character like I trust people more
easily and I tend to be overly giving
and when I met Layla it was like this
kind of unit I needed the Yang you know
what I mean I needed someone to balance
my like over optimism over trust like
yeah let's do something I need someone
to be like
you even seem like we had stayed there
she was like that was off I'm really
curious about that how what do you look
for is it is it to subconscious is it is
it a feeling you get what what red flags
stand out the most to you I I honestly
don't know I mean it's just like
instinctual I guess it's different with
every person like with that guy it was
like the moment I met him I was like he
just seems like a crook like and you
also have to look like situational
context which is Alex is when I'm at
Alex and I
I was like this is a very bright guy
who is surrounded by people that are
taking advantage of him who don't
necessarily mean that they don't mean to
take advantage of him but they can't
help it because he's smarter than them
he's better than them and so they're all
getting the better end of the deal like
he's doing more work and he's smarter
than them bringing more to the table and
it was really obvious to me and I
remember thinking like because I've
always considered like a lot of the I've
been a great supporter for people and so
I saw that and I was like he just needs
somebody that like really believes in
him and like can advocate for him like
rather than him doing that for other
people and so seeing that guy and like
meeting him I think
I just didn't trust the I don't know it
might I have no idea what it is honestly
I wish I can't put words to it because I
don't know what it is but like honestly
it might be because I pride myself on my
character so like my father has insanely
good character I've always prided myself
around like I can't be the smartest
person in the room but like I can have
really great character and so I look for
that in people more than anything more
than like smarts more than Intel like
anything I look at character and so I
think it's just if you look at something
all day you hire for it you filter your
friends for it you don't talk to family
because of it like it's just Forefront
of mind I mean I was just gonna add that
um
like I
a lot I had every one of the businesses
I had started up to that point except
for my very first gym
um which I very quickly brought Partners
into
um I always had this like fear of doing
it on my own right so I always just
wanted someone there
um
and when I look back on my business
trajectory like all the businesses that
I just did on my own I made a ton of
money and all the ones that I partnered
on I made not a lot of money and was
terrible and so like you know if if you
go in 10 relationships and everyone's
terrible it's like it might be you so I
might have been a bad partner which is
very possible or pick bad Partners or a
combination of those things but
um I think when Leila and I partnered up
I trusted Layla
um and I actually automatically even in
the first you know when I went to go
travel like in the very beginning to go
try this gym launch thing out I gave her
all my bank account passwords I told her
to go pick up the cash from all my
facilities every week and so she would
be handling like 11 grand every week and
just cash that she would just like pick
up from all the she'd just drive around
and pick up envelopes of like hundreds
and whatever and she just you know and
she was just depositing him for me
because
she's like this guy's ridiculous and to
be fair it is kind of ridiculous but
like I just felt like I could trust her
yeah did you ever get sketched out that
you're picking up envelopes of cash and
depositing on on Alex's behalf like that
could have been a thing where like now
you take the the call for it no I don't
think so I think I thought more that it
was ridiculous I'm like why would you
give this to me like I've you've known
me for a week like that's not a smart
idea and he was like I just know I can
trust you and I to myself I'm like well
obviously you can trust me but like how
do you know you know it's only been a
week yeah so you kind of lucked out in a
sense of like you had kind of been taken
advantage of by other partners time and
time again and then just one random time
you over trusted another person like you
had in the past but it had been the
right person and then it helped you just
for the record like I don't I I wish no
ill intent and even the guy that that
took everything like I hope he's doing
better
um I and I think a lot of those
Partnerships that didn't work it's not
like hey I wouldn't even describe it as
them I mean Layla uses a stronger
language because she was on the outside
but on the inside like I don't think
anyone had malicious intent I think that
that everyone came with skill sets and I
think that I tended to have more money
making skill sets you know at the time
and it worked out that way but like I
wish all those people you know
positive success you know since then
good question when you talk about money
making skill sets like what exactly were
those skill sets that were your money
making ones was like business Acumen
just raw intelligence was it like
experience I knew how to Market I knew
how to sell it was marketing and selling
that in the beginning I mean that's what
you need you got to know how to Market
you gotta know how to sell because if
you can't do that then there's no point
in like you can't get people to try your
thing
unless you get someone to buy it and so
it's like that's the first thing you
need is you need to learn how to promote
and you learn how to sell after that
then by all means fix the product get it
better improve it Etc and then that
becomes a much stronger Force but in the
beginning you gotta learn how to promote
and what were the biggest contributors
to that exact money making skill set the
marketing and selling was it reading or
experience no I mean it was uh I would
go to I went to a workshop in 2013 and
the guy taught Facebook ads in a weekend
and so I learned how to run Facebook ads
and I was like all right it wasn't as
simple as that though like I'm sure you
probably did tons no I mean it was it
was it was as simple as that really I
went there and he was like here's how
you run an ad and I was like okay what
year was this 2013 yes oh that's why
when no one was doing Facebook
yeah I've been very like there have been
a lot of things like I've been very
lucky you know what I mean like I'm at
Layla there are not many Layla's like I
recognize that not many there are not
many girls who are Persian who are into
fitness who love business
who want to just work all the time and
build something epic like a lot of girls
will say that because they want you to
like them and be with them but they
don't actually want that because then
they're always like hey you've worked
enough like let's go do this thing or
like if I'm working or if I'm like
editing the book and it's like four days
straight
it is what it is like this is this is my
life this is what I love doing and
we just made it work that way but like
anyways all that to say like I've been
very lucky in that way and I was lucky
at at that you know for that Workshop
which was only recommended to me by
chance by another guy that I was
supposed to partner with and he backed
out the night before which is why I got
the full gym rather than a 50 50 split
on my first one like there's a lot of
things that I lucked out on and so
like you know I was born you know my
dad's a doctor like I was lucky with
that I you know like there's a lot of
things that I lucked out on it's
interesting I don't picture you as
someone nor you really who necessarily
believes in luck so it's interesting you
say that I think I can be put into a
condition that has a higher likelihood
of a probable like a positive outcome
for sure if I were born in Bangladesh
like same everything the likelihood that
I'd be here significantly lower possible
yes likely significantly less likely
what do you think about that Layla I
think there's just things that you can't
control yeah and so it's like by
happenstance it's like hand it to you
yeah and so like I think about we talk
about like meeting each other because
people are like how do we get a
relationship like yours I'm like I don't
know like I don't have an answer because
I think we're really lucky to have met
each other and I don't think that this
relationship Dynamic would work for a
lot of other people that either of us
would have met you know so nor is it
common it's like how could we control to
make that circumstance happen you can't
really like you can you know try and
it's a numbers game and all that but
like think how many other people I know
because they send me screenshots they're
trying to find their Alex and Layla on
Bumble and they can't and so it's like
there's things like that that just
happen and you're like you just gotta
take the cards you're dealt you know and
be grateful for it it's interesting
because I think that like the single
great the single most important decision
that you make of all decisions in life
is who you spend your life with like as
your significant other and if you look
at all the stats in terms of amount of
time spent with people like time spent
with family basically drops off at 25
like it's very very low after that time
spent with siblings same thing time
spent with spend with friends starts
dropping off at like 30 pretty
aggressively and then the two that
increase a lot for the majority of your
life are time spent with spouse is
number one and then in between those is
time spent with co-workers so your
co-workers matter way more than your
friends do in terms of hours per day so
like where you work is actually
incredibly important for your overall
like your subjective well-being but like
there's one person that you're going to
spend the rest of your life with if you
believe in marriage and like the
strength of the relationship you have
with your significant other has a 0.71
correlation to your overall subjective
well-being so more than anything how
well you get along with the person you
spend all your time with which makes
sense you spend the majority of your
time with this person and so I think
that if there's ever something to be
obsessive over it would be that you saw
that chart on Twitter huh which the
chart the X and Y and then you have it
was a bunch of lines yeah who post what
is that it was uh it was this thing that
I saw on Twitter and it basically was
just obviously X and Y yeah and then you
had a line and it's age and then it each
different mine had a different color
showing you know different groups of
people you would spend your time with
children like you said co-workers spouse
and it shows over time and they
obviously all average up to 100 on the
y-axis and it just shows the lines
change that's a great account go follow
them yeah yeah he's got great stuff and
that so like it just further proves the
like at least for me you know I mean
like Caleb's here and he knows but like
I will buy
60 pairs of shorts and wear all of them
to figure out which one is the one that
I like the most I'll buy 40 pairs of
barefoot shoes to figure out the one
that I like the most like I do that with
everything can you say because everyone
was asking the last time you came on no
I won't you will not say I haven't
responded to mine they haven't responded
to my DM no I'm not really is there any
way we can get somehow put them in touch
with you like I feel like oh um
you shout them out once and everyone I
already did I did one time still you
shouted them out yeah I did I did they
didn't respond and where could people
find it what
so I want to ask just a general
relationship question so I I believe
that there are mainly three pillars to a
successful relationship such as shared
values cool shared interests and just
raw chemistry right okay I think those
are the three things as long as you can
check those three boxes everything else
obviously it matters to some extent but
those are the main three boxes you need
to check to make sure your partner is a
viable one I swapped with one of I swap
one of them out which one so chemistry
out swap because that's going to
disappear in terms of like literally
your chemical soup and your brain goes
back to normal after two years so like
that that feeling goes away and so what
I would swap with that is something long
term which is Mission which is do you
want to do the same thing on earth
just like shared Mission values is how
you so do you want to go to the same
place yeah this is how you get there and
interest is the stuff you do along the
way Tony Robbins talks about it a lot
but you can create chemistry yeah in
fact we've talked about it a ton because
we have to manage our chemistry because
of how much we work together yeah how do
you do that space how do you create
space so many ways I mean independent
vacations
[Laughter]
I'm going to Mexico we'll meet back in
the US no I mean I think some of it's
physical space which is like you know we
technically work together all day right
but we don't we stay in separate areas
of the house we work on different things
like we're very segmented in terms of
our responsibilities set in terms of
what we do in the business and outside
and then on the other side of that it's
being able to switch hats which is
there's Alex and Layla that work
together and you see in the public eye
and then there's Alex and Layla that are
themselves in their condo when nobody's
their husband and wife and so it's being
able to switch between those two
Dynamics because if you constantly keep
on the work hat then like there's no
chemistry you know what I mean because
what happens is you're not it's the side
of you that provokes chemistry and the
person like for a woman right for me
it's like am I being feminine I'm
playful and funny and you know
light-hearted well it's like at work I'm
not going to beat those things because
it's more of like a masculine energy at
work where you're like driving things
forward making decisions like very
decisive outspoken so for me it's been
learning how to swap the hats and I
think we've both worked on that a lot
over the years
um so now it feels easy I mean now it
feels like the moment people leave like
we talk in a different voice yeah like
our manners
I do a little bit Yeah like a little
playful
um no I think I think the things that's
improved is that we've got our our speed
to be able to change gears has improved
so what used to maybe take like an hour
or two hours to wind down like to switch
gears is now like we can do it in almost
an instant
um and so that's that's been like being
able to shift energy is really like the
the Crux of it like you can feel like
right now you have business Alex and
Layla like this is like we can talk
objectively about the marriage but this
isn't like our relationship Dynamic you
know what I mean this is our work
dynamic because this is work you know I
mean for us you know what I mean but
when we are when we're you know at home
alone like
we're pretty playful you know what I
mean like we we tell a lot of jokes we
like we'll we'll [ __ ] with each other a
lot like there's a lot of practical
lights and stuff just like we're really
funny yeah it's just a lot of country
like we just yeah we're pretty goofy and
we're it's incredibly light-hearted
which is a strong just juxtapose against
probably what most people see which is
just like hard charging incredibly
stoic Work Hard Play Hard business yeah
but what if something is going on with
the business between you two maybe a
disagreement that you have on that how
does that not bleed over an affect that
heart we've had disagreements and we've
walked out the door and looked at each
other and just said I love you yeah and
then we just move on to like we're not
in this disagreement currently and and
being in a dis and like again this like
I think we're very fortunate with this
because
so as a reminder to the audience like we
pretty much started doing business
together day one and so like we've only
had a business Dynamic if anything we
had to work harder on the relationships
are the Romantic side then the business
side so like business came natural to us
like it was like a first language for us
and then we learned the romance act
which is why she was saying like you can
create chemistry like you can do it like
you just do the things and like the
camera she's there with disagreements we
that they're short-lived and a lot of
times like I think we're pretty good at
compartmentalizing it like if we
disagree about something we know that we
are aligned with the same Mission we
know we're aligned with the same values
and so the only thing that we will
disagree about is like the best way to
get there and a lot of times I think
both of us are like
is this a hill you're going to die on
and neither of us really die on many
Hills and so it's only if we do it's
really important it's shared probably
yeah and one of the rules that we had
which is one of the most important roles
we had in the very beginning of our
relationship was we had this like goo or
Guru or whatever like talked to us and
he was like
I don't know what that was yeah I don't
know what it was but like the advice was
good and he said if you don't agree on
something don't move forward and for
whatever reason it struck Us in the
moment and we have stuck to that which
is like and usually it's like Alex wants
to do something and Layla's like I'm not
sure and because of the positive
reinforcement that I've had earlier on
in our relationship from like most times
when I was like I'm gonna do this thing
she was like I don't think that's a good
idea and I did it anyways most times
those things blew up and so she has a
very good track record for that and so
now we have like a very like we like to
joke that like if I weren't here we
wouldn't have a business but if Layla
were not here I would have a hundred and
also not have a business and so it's
like it's the it's the drawbridge it's
the tension between these two extremes
which is where I think the magic happens
for us interesting I've heard like if
it's not a hell yes then it's just a no
well from a deal perspective absolutely
but like from uh like which way like
we're agreed on this direction we're
agreed on this strategy like how are we
tactically going to execute that like
there's there's a million permutations
you can have and so like if we do don't
agree
because I get this question something
we're like well somebody's got to have
veto right right so if you're if you're
at a standstill
we just don't like I don't think that's
real like if you're in a business and
you disagree you keep talking about it
until you agree like it just you keep
beating the idea and thinking about
upsides and downsides and risks Etc
exposure and then you're like
I see where you're coming from let's
emphasize that you know like you just
keep solving for it and I think being
open and not taking it personally
especially we're in the business setting
because we both know because we've done
this enough times that like we both just
want to win
and so it's just like how we both have a
hundred percent alignment so just like
we don't take it personal how do you
keep the emotions out of it I think that
we are able to admit when we are
emotional yeah exactly so if I'm if
we're in a some kind of disagreement
I'll be like listen I'm just too
stressed with this like I need to go on
a walk or something and then let's talk
about it later or if Alex he might be
like I'm too angry like let's I'm gonna
go do something and we'll talk about it
later so I think we usually are pretty
self-aware of like if we're in an
emotional state and if we are we try to
wait until we're not to then come back
and talk about it then you know what I
mean I think it's a really big point is
that like we don't we actively avoid
discussion when there's emotional charge
it's just not productive you know what I
mean yeah and even sometimes like I mean
I as a woman it's like I have to catch
myself and be like Oh I'm acting crazy
right now I'm gonna go and he's like and
I'm like yeah I'm gonna go because I'm
acting like crazy [ __ ] and like I can
now catch myself within like two minutes
like we'll be in a conversation and it's
like if I can feel that I'm just being
emotional like oh
so sorry crazy going leaving now exiting
myself from the room for you that has to
be so nice that has to be incredible
yeah yeah it's great I mean I think
people should be with people who are
reasonable but now do you get emotional
too I get angry okay yeah I get angry
um and so for me it's like I have to
cool off like just like I can just feel
like it's not like I'm an outburst type
guy but like I get very cold and I get
incredibly like cutting and sharp with
like
wrong like I am right and you just don't
see it yet because I have to explain
this to you in very slow terms so that
you can catch up that's how I will be
when I'm angry and um it's not good it's
not good for the team you know Etc and
so when I get in that in that zone I can
usually feel it and then I'm like I need
like sometimes it takes you know it
takes training you know like you do it
and then I'll go on a 45 minute you know
this is years ago you know I mean random
about something and she was like that
didn't come across too well you know
because we're a lot of times we're Team
facing you know we're talking to our
team we're talking to you know whatever
um and so like now I think we've gotten
faster and faster at like just pulling
it back but it's not that we eliminate
how do you take a step back do you just
go on a different room do you
go do a workout how do you do that
really interesting so one of the things
that we found this has just worked well
for us is that be it text like text
communication we are really good
and so like it kind of removes it gives
you it gives you a little bit more time
to say what you're going to say you know
I mean there's also a record of it you
know what I mean and so if we're
honestly it's like it's been something
that we've done a lot which is like if
we're in a disagreement we'll like type
it out and typing it out it gives it
literally gives you delay between when
you feel something and when something
gets delivered and you get to see it
before like you don't have the slips of
the tongue because you see the words and
you're like committing to them when you
send them and that's been honestly one
of the at least from a tactical
perspective one of the most valuable
things that we've done to like defuse
situations I think it works if you're
logical which we are we both want to
discuss things in a reasonable logical
manner I think if you're really just
emotional you're just gonna find a
reason as to why texting doesn't work
because you can't because emotion
doesn't have a good argument right so
when you type it out it doesn't make any
sense I agree with that entirely one
thing that I tell my close friends is
that if they're ever feeling extremely
emotional angry sad whatever they should
Journal because the thing is when you're
writing stuff down let's say your brain
is functioning at like 200 words per
minute or 300 I don't know what it is
right your hand can only write 40. right
so there's a longer Delay from like the
emotion that you're feeling and the
brain activity to when you're actually
writing you basically have to put more
emphasis on each word and more thought
into each word and it comes off as more
calculated than emotional so yeah it's
very therapeutic it's worked super well
for go ahead yeah I mean I I was just
gonna say I think it's that and I think
we've also learned how to how to
disagree with each other more
productively and how to manage each
other when we're in emotional state so
like if Alex is angry like back is six
years ago I probably made him more angry
when I was trying to help him not be
angry now I feel like I understand what
diffuses Alex she's really good at
diffusion what diffuses it
just being really nice honestly a lot of
times it's like I turn into like a cute
little ball of fun she basically turns
on her like her relationship hat and
then like it I I it's like you can't hit
a puppy you know what I mean like you
can but like but like it's a lot harder
yeah and so if I'm like in this very
like aggressive you know what I mean
like Zone and she's just being like
really cute and kind of vulnerable I
like it it I defuse really quickly he
can't help but laugh you know what I
mean or smile I just have this right
smile and be like all right you know I
mean heard you know what I mean and then
it like we kind of go from there and
like for Layla a lot of times like she
just like she just needs like a long hug
and being like it's okay you know what I
mean like it's time to get stressed he
gets angry like she gets stressed I get
angry and so for me it's like it's okay
like you can feel this way and it's
totally fine and normal yeah when was
the decision to get married 11 months
after dating after our first date yeah
11 months in yeah it was uh six days
later
we had talked about it like a couple
times up until then I think it's more
just like we were like we like looked up
one day and I think people in the
business were asking us they were like
are you guys gonna get buried and I was
like I don't know I'm So Young you know
she was 23. and then we started talking
about we're like interesting they're all
asking us if we're getting married and
we're like do they feel like it's not
stable well that was actually a big
point they were like job security wise
like we feel weird you know committing
to this and you guys aren't even
committed to each other you know what I
mean like what happens if you guys break
up and both of us were like we just keep
doing the same thing like we'll keep
running this business nobody believes
you though yeah No One Believes you but
like as a side note for the dudes who
are like considering getting a girl into
their into their business like you have
to have objectively been willing to pick
that girl of all people to do that role
but I think happens more often is guys
are like man I want to involve my wife
in the business who doesn't really like
business and then they pull them in they
don't give them the respect because
maybe that's not warranted because they
don't have the Acumen for it or whatever
and then they give them kind of a peon
roll which that doesn't necessarily
breed even more respect
um so that they can be like quote
involved
I think like
the role has to be the role that you
would pick for that person even if you
had no dog in the fight like if you
didn't have the relationship like if we
weren't together I would still want
Layla basically running all the
companies because she's great at it it's
why we do well
yeah it's 100 Merit and so like we just
get the benefit of the fact that like
we're also married but like skills first
like the position has to be earned so do
you think the marriage was in a way to
satisfy business partners yeah and so it
was the it was the employees yeah and
then so I so I came back or go ahead
yeah I mean I I yeah I think it was a
mix of things I mean I think I wouldn't
say the employees are the reason that we
got married I think yeah I think it was
just like it just felt like it made a
lot of sense I mean honestly that's like
what we came to it's just like this
makes a ton of sense like we're running
a business together we're romantically
involved we're building the same
together it looks like it's like blowing
up where like it just makes more sense
to get married than it doesn't did you
have a contract prior to then in terms
what would happen if you guys split like
who owns what and who gets what or no
well I mean we didn't have much but but
Alex did this was growing at that point
it was growing but I think at that point
did we both have 50 50. I can't remember
the business was all mine at that point
yeah the business was yours at that
point yeah I just didn't even you know
it's so weird because like I never even
thought about that because like
literally what I did test is women who
take things for men like when I I won't
tell that but
seeing that women are willing to take
something from a man rather than start
over and like get your like it was just
never even in my mind like a possibility
you know what I mean like I was like I
would rather jump off a cliff than take
money from somebody so I actually asked
Layla to sign a prenup because I think
I'd like 250 Grand or something squirrel
away
and she was like sure whatever and the
fact that she was just like so
effortlessly a yes and I had actually
asked a former relationship to sign a
prenup and it was like a big deal and
very painful and horrible and whatever
the fact that she was just like sure no
problem when we were on the way to like
get it notarized or whatever I actually
just tore it up and threw it out the
window I was like we're good you know I
mean like you've risked everything at
every single point you like you chose me
and wanted to do this thing together
like let's do it you know what I mean
and so I um yeah my proposal I didn't
have a ring I was just like I think the
actual question was I think it would
make sense if we got married what do you
think
how much forethought did you give the
wedding or or the proposal in general
was was like from start to finish was it
like a week a month
was it flowers
I mean it's funny because like I I say
what I said earlier like it is the most
important decision but like the so this
is counter-cultural is that if you look
at like the ROM comes right that are out
there there's usually like Mr right and
then like the old flame from home right
and then they have to like break up with
Mr Right to be with the old flame but
the reason they don't have like sequels
for rom-coms is because then you'd have
two people who are married and have no
reason to be together and so it would be
a very boring movie that would just be
like a miserable marriage and so I
actually think that Mr Right the one
that makes sense on paper that you have
all the logical reasons to be together
is the person that Hollywood should be
getting people to get married to because
when the chemistry Fades you need to
have rational reasons to be with that
person because like when bad days come
and they will you need to still be like
this makes sense right it still makes
sense when it doesn't make sense and you
don't have the feeling it's tough right
and so
um I remember I was listing it out
because when we were like in this one
marriage discussion I was like I mean
you have the cultural background which
is just a bonus like I never looked for
like a Persian girl but like the fact
that she was was great
um so she understand kind of the
cultural background of my whole family
and whatnot she loved business which was
awesome and she loved Fitness and like
being active and eating healthy and
working out and like that was pretty
much the only three things that like
were interesting or you know and she was
kind right and like trustworthy and she
had character and so I was like I don't
I didn't see a world where there was a
high likelihood that I would find
somebody else that had all those things
and had already sacrificed all these
things to be you know to do this thing
and had shown efficacy at being good at
it
I was like I just feel like it makes
sense if we get married and she was she
was like yeah and so she said yes and
then we literally I was like all right I
guess I need to get you a ring so we'd
got in the car drove the jewelry store
bought a ring we both liked the same one
so she got that drove back called the
pastor and I was like when are you free
and he was like this Wednesday he's like
are you sure this is fast and we're like
yeah we're good and so the whole week
leading up was six days from then until
we got married and she was like who's
gonna chicken out and um it was crazy
that I had backed out of a wedding which
was really hard by the way
um super Hardy expectations on both
sides like invites all this stuff
um but I thought I was gonna like I
thought that I had commitment issues
but it was just that in my gut I knew it
was the right person and I think that
was the like that's why I commanded you
so it's like it's just a lot of people
haven't found the right person like if
you like if you're like not if you don't
know you know kind of thing and so it
just made sense to do it and so then we
got married in the back of a church on a
Wednesday night
um with no family nothing there was like
some local friends who showed up like
five six people and that was it what
caused you to walk away the first time
especially so late in the in the process
I think it was kind of what you'd
consider like the traditional Hollywood
relationship of like the hot and the
cold the in you're out you're up then
you're down like it just it's just so
much emotional like
drama and like chemicals and just all
you know like all of that very like
intoxicating very heavy relations
distracted too and you know
fundamentally like I would say there was
tons of chemistry but like none of like
a lot of the other stuff we didn't share
so like we had Different World Views we
had different missions for our lives
personally
um and we didn't really have the same
interests so all we had was chemistry
and so that's why it made it so hard
because you have Opposites Attract and
you have this like like uh well if you
don't like this and we can't be together
it's like but I miss you and you did
like this whole thing in like the
relationship that I had with Layla was
literally the exact opposite of that it
was just like everything made sense it
was like this is what I think it's like
oh that makes sense yeah and to someone
that's been dating someone else for
let's say a year two maybe three years
how do they know to make that final like
you know to tie the ribbon to make sure
okay you are going to be my spouse how
do what is the deciding factoring that
to someone who's been dating someone for
a while I mean I think I don't think
that there is a deciding factor in the
in this context of I don't think
everyone has to get married you know
what I mean like I think
we wanted to get married and like we
both see ourselves like being with
somebody like we would like to have this
marriage for the rest of our lives like
that's something that we've communicated
to each other but I think a lot of
people don't want that and so I think a
lot of people should take one step back
and think like do I even want marriage
and if so what's the purpose because I
think that it's going to become less and
less popular in my opinion
um and there's a lot of people it
doesn't really make sense for like it
really doesn't have a lot of benefits
um particularly like you look at like
the decline on birth rates and stuff
like if you're not going to have kids
like if you don't have kids you don't
share business together you don't share
a lot of your lives together like I
don't really understand why someone
would get married how is it for your
family because I know with with the
Persian culture it's very close so how
is it having a wedding and not having
friends cousins fifth cousins you know
uncles uh it's like everybody there well
we did that on purpose yeah because we
um didn't want that yeah we didn't want
that a be like the whole concept of a
wedding to me was very like it that
never made sense to me like why are we
going to spend 50 Grand everything
marked up 500 percent just to have
everyone else come there and see
everyone for five seconds like that that
just didn't make sense to me and so like
we worked the day that we got we got
married and we worked the next day like
we didn't take a honeymoon it was just
like you went to the thing signed the
papers and and we still haven't taken a
honeymoon we haven't done any of that
stuff
um but we didn't tell our parents
because we knew that they would be
against it we need to be like you're
moving too fast this is too extreme and
like that's how my dad was like you're
always so extreme you always go so all
in on stuff and I mean her dad was you
know not a fan of me earlier on so not
that he wasn't a fan like he would have
said it was fast and he would have said
I think same thing just too fast you
guys are young what are you doing this
business thing it's confusing yeah slow
down and now they're all oh yeah my dad
loves Alex yeah now what about for you
growing up did you have that vision of
having that big wedding and that giant
proposal no I didn't
um
I just always thought it was so fake you
know what I mean like I'm like what's
the point like I don't want to spend all
that money on a wedding like that was
always my thought was like why spent all
that money on a wedding when like you
should be spending that money on the
rest of your life being married to this
person like if we put that much effort
into the marriage imagine how much
better our lives would be yeah but we
put all this effort into a wedding and
so that's always how I looked at it and
I think I always just wanted it to be
more private you know I'm like I don't
I'm not somebody who like loves a ton of
attention so I think the idea of also
like having a wedding and being in front
doing all this stuff like that's not
comfortable to me I think I just always
wanted to be like it should be about us
not about everybody else you know what I
mean it's like I always thought like it
seems like weddings are way more about
appeasing other people rather than doing
what is authentic to you and what's
authentic to me has never been a huge
wedding it's been a meaningful marriage
that is something that's you know
important to me and so I like the way
that we did it because it was just us
and it was in like
it was a reflection of the rest of our
lives and who each of us are you know
like we don't like doing things like
everybody else and because of that like
we just do things our own way yeah and I
had you know
um just because I have experienced
proposing twice
um the first time I was you know I was
asked by the family they're like so
what's the plan because I you know told
them I was going to do it or whatever I
went to like the more normal traditional
path and I was like I just was planning
on just asking her at like the grocery
store or something because that's like
real life you know what I mean like this
is what I'm asking to do not some big
Fanfare and they were like that's
because you're being selfish and you're
not thinking about her and you need to
do something that she's gonna be really
excited about so I did this whole big
Fanfare and it felt inauthentic to me
because I'm like this is just not my
vibe you know what I mean like this is
me like this is how I am and so like the
engagement or the proposal that I had
with Layla but me just being like I
think it would make sense we got married
and like here's why like that's me like
that's me and if I had to not be myself
in what would be considered a very
memorable pivotal moment of the
relationship like I think that was for
me a little bit of a precursor to why It
ultimately didn't end up working out
um I have nothing but love her and we've
ever been with
um huge seasons in my life but like
that just long term it didn't I don't
think it made sense but one of the
things that Layla and I did that I think
was really cool was that in the very
beginning of our marriage we did a lot
of uh we went through like courses and
workshops on uh divorced and at-risk
marriages so we started going through
all these workshops of people who are
like trying to figure out their marriage
and we learned a ton of stuff about like
how to communicate and like expectation
setting and just a lot of really
interesting things and um I think it
served us well so I highly recommend
going through like divorce and like
Crisis marriage counseling type stuff
what did you learn from that I think
one fundamental thing that has to be
learned in order to have a productive
relationship with so many of the
opposite sex is like how men and women
are different like how our brains work
differently how we think differently how
we receive love and affection
differently or respect
um and I think that that teaches you how
you can't treat your partner like you
want to be treated yeah you have to
learn to treat your partner like they
want to be treated and I think that
that's fundamentally hard to learn when
you're not of the same sex so it's like
you have to learn like how does a guy
want to be treated how does a guy
receive love how does a woman want to be
treated how does a woman receive love
and I think that was a huge piece of it
along with
understanding like the kind of
protection mechanisms that we had each
built up along the way that had created
walls between us and I think that those
walls took a couple of years to probably
come down maybe two or three because
like I know for myself like over the
years like you build up walls that keep
you from getting hurt but they also keep
you from getting super close to somebody
and I think everybody has those it's
completely normal and you shouldn't wait
to find someone to you know until those
walls are down I think it's you learn
how to take them down with your partner
yeah and so it's like you become aware
of them yourself and then you explore
that with your partner you talk about it
openly and then you talk about how
you're going to work on it and I think
that being able to communicate those few
things with each other was huge for us
like I used to be very cold and I
wouldn't tell Alex anything that was on
my mind I mean I was extremely closed
off and that was really tough for me and
for him and for me one of the things
that I had to work on the most was
learning how to just communicate what I
was actually thinking and not be so
terrified that he would judge me or you
know leave or mad at me or anything
because just for some reason I just
never I always was like used to doing
things on my own and so feeling like I
could even tell somebody else how I was
feeling about anything was like
so incredibly overwhelming for me and
now it's normal and I can you know if
anything it's like maybe five minutes of
me not telling him but it used to be
weeks yeah yeah what do you think you
had to work on
it's great you know I'm not that yet I
think I think uh my temper has gotten a
lot better
um that's that's a big one uh my timer's
got a lot better
um because I think what it was is like
your if Alex would get angry then Layla
would recoil yeah it was like and then
it was not a productive relationship so
you worked a ton on understanding like
anger
didn't work with me at all very true
like I would just get more aggressive
and then like she would just shut down
and so I just had to like I just had to
create more space and learn how to like
okay
like this is what we want to do these
are the values like that's why it's like
the mission values interest is so at
least for us is so important is like if
we're aligned on these things then it
means that all we have for the mo nine
times out of ten it's a miscommunication
like nine times out of ten it just means
like I took something that you said the
way that you probably didn't intend it
so let's just break down what you said
and how I took it and then she's like I
didn't mean that to disrespect you I was
like well here's when you say this I was
like this is what I hear she's like I
did not mean that and so like I think
over time like you just know that there
are trigger sentences or whatever that
I'm like I could probably work on this
but it'd be a hell of a lot easier if
you just don't say that and I will also
concurrently try to work on it if it
slips out I think we have so much
ability to influence our partners and we
have to be careful with that you know
what I mean because it's like I only
want to encourage Alex and I'm sure Alex
only wants to encourage me but we can
say things and not know that we're
discouraging the other person to spy our
behaviors and our actions and is it our
full responsibility no but it was it's
definitely helpful if you know how to
positively affect that person rather
than negatively and I think a lot of
people in relationships actually
negatively impact their Partners more
than they positively do and that's why
people break up because if they look at
that area of their life and many other
areas they're negatively impacted once
they get with that person you know it's
like they look at the time they got in
the relationship it's like health wealth
all these friends everything it's like
it all goes down versus you know for us
it all went up I had a I had a mentor so
you asked the question way earlier about
like how do you know if it's like the
right person I don't think there's like
a one fits all but I asked this to a
coach that I had at the time who was
kind of like basically helping me deal
with the anxiety that I was going
through and all that stuff was happening
and he was like just look at your stats
that's what he told me he's like just
look at your stats he's like
how are you Fitness wise I was like is
it up or down being with her I was like
well she goes to the gym all the time
she like does all the meal prep like
it's up I'm definitely like better
because she's there he's like all right
what about the business stuff I was like
well
I was like well she makes me money and
he was like has any other girl made you
money I was like no and he's like well
that's a plus right and I was like okay
and so you know we just went down the
line of like what are the things that no
matter most to me and like are they
pluses or minuses and all of them were
up my stats were up since I've been with
Leyland I never like really thought
through that and I was like oh like this
logically like I'm better for being with
her and so it was also like how's your
headspace are you more you know what I
mean you know like I feel like you're
becoming a better version you're a worse
version of you
um because like there's some people who
have Partnerships like that's how we see
it like spouse Partnerships that like
all they do is emphasize the worst
character traits of you it's like if
your you know partner is always like
like no let's let's stay in or let's
let's drink or let's you know not to say
that these things are bad in small doses
but like if everything you have is
always like decreasing all your stats to
be with this person like long term for
people who are growth oriented which not
that many people are but for people who
are growth oriented I think having
somebody who holds you to a higher
standard like I know that Layla has
extremely high expectations of me and I
have very high expectations of her and
we just always want to exceed one
another's expectations as the bar
continues to rise because like as you
get better so too do your Alternatives
by like other people who you attract are
better quality and so we both want to be
in like you think about this way a
voluntary relationship like of all the
people I still want to be with you and
that like because what happens a lot of
people one person grows and the other
person doesn't and like
it's just like if one person's growing
they both have to grow yep I don't think
it's gonna work long term yeah well I
think if one person is growing the
other's not the other would be
intimidated by that person growing and
then fearing that that person might
leave yeah maybe that's a reason why
they wouldn't want the other person to
grow yeah and then they seek to control
them in some way yeah they manipulate
and they subvert you know yeah not good
so how do you think the dynamic has
changed before and after marriage for
you guys
because it seems like on paper just on
the surface like nothing has changed
besides just a legal standing but is
there a dynamic that's maybe different
now I would say the one thing that's
really weird is when we got married yeah
like you know before you're married you
still have like these little thoughts in
the back of your head about like other
people that were around like you still
think about those people like you still
think about some of those X's that you
like got back together with and you're
like maybe and there's you know what it
is you have possibility
so there's like a lot of possibility of
what your future could look like even
though you're you're with this person
but you're not married yet it's like
there's still a lot of possibilities so
you see a lot of alternative futures for
yourself when you get married all of
that noise in your head just goes away
and it's like possibility is like it's
gone and you're very certain about what
your future is going to look like so
there's less possibility right because
you know you're with one person now but
then you're very certain about what
everything's going to look like going
forward and so it's like all that
ancillary noise and like thinking about
other people and dating and all that
it's just gone so this was this is like
a fun like mini segue but Layla had a
bunch of dudes who were always hollering
right and like even on like her birthday
I think she got like two gifts from
other dudes you know what I mean and we
were like together and um I was like
what
um and uh
I was like you know that these their
shoes they're like they're just friends
and I was like they are not friends I
was like they were trying to [ __ ] you
like and she was like no they're just
friends I was like
guys are not going to be friends with
girls to be friends with them I was like
if they want to have a friend they'll go
find a guy like and they'll be like why
are they gonna go pretend to be
interested in what you're like they're
that's not what it is and so we had this
was like an ongoing like not in a
malicious way but it was like almost
like a joke throughout like the early
days before we got married the day she
changed her marital status
all of them befriended her and I was
like
just saying
unfollowed yeah
what was that like for you going to I
mean I thought it was pretty funny you
know I was like really this whole time
like eight years you know like yeah like
it's really not friends
there's a term on Reddit they call it
beta male orbiters
right yeah that's what it was it was
just like oh you're so so great awesome
stuff like whatever like neutral
comments you didn't mean to like yeah
yeah whatever and I was like these guys
are not your friends like they're just
you know what I mean they're planting
seeds and hoping someday that it'll
Sprout yeah I thought it was funny
because I just I I've always been like
super naive like there's so many times
where I end up on date and I was like
this is a date like I thought you just
said you wanted to grab coffee like yeah
like a date I'm like
that's date I thought you would say it's
a date you know so I was just always
pretty aloof and uh yeah it's not just
you though I think that's a very common
Dynamic of relationships between guys
and girls even me like growing up in
high school I don't think it's
necessarily impossible for guys and
girls to be friends but I do think more
often than not there has to be some sort
of hidden motive there and as upsetting
as it is to be a ratio right maybe like
20 of friendships could be genuine yeah
maybe 80 like the majority you're
probably not yeah I would say it's
possible to be generous but you think 90
10.
this is just my personal anecdotal
experience you know like I think that's
tough yeah yeah and it's not just you
it's just girls in general they can be
so they can be oblivious to that stuff
and that's just I did not have friend
girls
like I barely had friends so like let
alone like if I'm gonna actually hang
out with anyone's gonna be a dude like
I'm you know like if I actually just
want to like chill and relax if you were
to give a ratio what would you say I
would say 85. I'll meet in the middle
here 85 15. so 15 seconds sure I'll do
85 is pretty good 85 90. what would you
give it ah that sounds about right I
mean like for me okay
Fair yeah probably and I want to be
clear there are probably some guys who
somehow managed to do it yeah me
personally I was never a guy friend
which is why her comment was so funny to
me because I was like never once in my
entire life because I'm also a very
clear Communicator yeah so I was like
here are my intentions with you like
they are not they're not pure in nature
you know I mean like I want to be with
you and that's how in no uncertain terms
like I made my attention it's clear
because I also didn't want the [ __ ]
so if someone's like I don't see that
way I'm like cool like not trying to be
friends you know I mean like I I can't
the amount of times where I was just
like I'm not friend material like that
is not why I'm here you know what I mean
was like I was just very explicit
um and some people like that some people
didn't that's fine either way that's me
so anyways this would be probably I
probably projected a little bit of like
my own like I don't have friends who are
girls on to her but in this instance I
have have been right which was
confirming
um but as a guy to shift back to the
original question did things change when
you got married right
um one obviously all the side combos
stop
um and then for me there was actually a
huge amount of like noise that like
disappeared because like especially when
I was single like I would say the
majority of my time and attention went
to like girls like and like you know
what I mean like in terms of just
headspace like texting organizing dates
trying to you know what I mean like a
lot of my mental bandwidth even if it
wasn't ours but like in between time
went to that and the moment we got
married it was like all of this
attention
of like something else could happen was
just gone and then it was just us and
this business and then I mean then it
just like it ripped you know what I mean
like that's when we got like we went
from making a few hundred thousand
dollars a month to a few million a month
like 12 months later like it was just
like we were both like you're in I'm in
let's go and that was like and it was
like
we just we're both able to attract other
people you know what I mean and so just
having that security and that knowledge
like you're my person for the
foreseeable future it just it just
washed away all of this attention that
came back to focusing on the main thing
so how did your schedules change after
that because I mean the business did
really well from that aspect where you
guys was like all right now we can just
focus so what was it what was there's a
lot of that it's kind of like the extra
headspace because we're both Believers
in like split attention like even if
like that's why we don't like
like if you know what you want to do I'm
not a big fan of side hustles because it
distracts you know what I mean like it's
not it's just like it's it's a tension
it's shower time it's drive time that
could be that Creative Energy that Juju
that extra time if it were reallocated
to the main thing like it compounds
faster right most people like just have
enough they spread it and there's like
there's a threshold that you have to get
above to beat everybody else right like
the people you're competing against are
focused the guys who are winning are
focused like you it's very arrogant to
think that I can spread my attention to
be better than other people who are all
in on this one thing and so one thing
all in was was how we saw it yeah I
don't think anything actually changed
like in the Physical Realm it's really
just like mentally yeah you just don't
worry about it yeah and how do you make
sure you have enough time for each other
in the mix of everything that you do you
know I'll say this side no God we've
tried that I hate that [ __ ] they're like
date night don't talk about work after X
hours it's relation we tried that [ __ ]
and let me tell you we were [ __ ]
miserable I hate that [ __ ] so much and I
think it's some [ __ ] that people
have to put if you don't have values
that you lead your life by then you need
rules like we don't talk about work on
date night and that is exactly what most
people do but we have values which is we
value our marriage and we value the
business therefore we naturally allocate
attention between both of them and I
think that most people aren't led by
those values and that's why they have to
default to those rules but if you are
led by values then it's not something
that you have to put a huge amount of
effort towards it's hey it's a it's a
dichotomy to manage right which is like
the the relationship which is like if
you're completely focused on the
relationship then you're distracted from
where you're going and your mission in
life but if you're completely aloof from
the relationship then you probably feel
a little bit of anxiety because you're
feeling like am I secure am I not it's a
dichotomy to manage and I think that
it's just being able to catch yourself
it's like most people swing on a
pendulum right where it's like we're
completely obsessed in this relationship
or we're completely aloof and distracted
elsewhere it's like if you can just get
to the middle faster which is where
everyone wants to be which is like we
pay attention to our relationship and to
other things in life it's productive
then I think that you'll be a lot
happier and so that's what we really try
to do which is like if I feel like I
need time with Alex I tell Alex that you
know if Alex feels like he needs time
with me he tells me if we say that we
want to go on a trip we go on a trip you
know I mean like it's just
being able to use your natural intuition
in terms of like this feels a little off
and not judge yourself about it and not
judge the situation not be like we suck
we're so bad at being married because we
haven't done a date in so long it's like
well [ __ ] we've been busy you want to go
on a date though
you know yeah
I hate to take a little two-minute
intermission but I've drank way too much
water oh Jack I'm sorry you got a phone
I can I can hold it I'm just gonna be
like antsy all right go sorry
yeah but I didn't know I was going to
get a phone call Dad you could use this
bathroom oh we're gonna we're gonna hear
him take a poop yeah it's like gonna
hear like a plunk down I'll just
continue
um
where do you guys feel like you could
improve or is there any weakness that
you have that that you're working on in
the very beginning of covid I think that
was like a great season for our marriage
I liked our marriage during twenty
totally five extra marriage
um I think that when we were selling the
business I think was another season
where we put more attention to the
marriage I think right now we're putting
way more attention to the business like
in the last 10 months and so I think
that we just I think we're really good
at acknowledging the seasons that we're
in being okay with them and then and not
judging ourselves for it you know what I
mean like and I think it all that
matters is that you're on the same page
if you are in a season of like I'm
putting all my attention on work but
your spouse is like I'm putting all my
attention on you that's when you get
resentment right and that's when
marriages don't work but we both always
agree and we talk about it transparently
hey this is a season where we're going
all in on work versus hey this is a
season where it's really nice that we
get to enjoy each other more and I think
it's the best way that you can balance
is just like being open about it and
also just not I don't think that I think
Life Works it's like you have health
wealth relationship all these things
right and if you want to grow one thing
the rest kind of have to go on
maintenance so like I would say right
now our marriage is probably on
maintenance it was in growth when we
were selling the business because we
didn't have a business to focus on it
was on growth during covid because we
had a lot of ancillary time and it'll be
in growth again once we have a little
more space from the business but right
now we've agreed that we want to put
that focus on the business and then
we'll come back to the relationship and
so that's how I see it I think the the
biggest issue that comes up is where
there's discrepancies so where where
there's just mismatched expectations
between the spouses and reality or how
they're how they see it and I think one
of the worst things that I see kind of
in the dating marriage whatever industry
is the labels that they ascribe to
situations or kind of to Layla's Point
like they're like if you're not ex if
you're not having a date night once a
week if you're talking about business if
you're they just insert something they
then say it's bad right and so if both
let's say that let's say hypothetically
Layla and I were so busy with work that
we did nothing but work and didn't have
a meal together for a month if we both
didn't have a problem with it because it
was the season that we were in
other people might say that's bad what
they really mean is I don't prefer that
in which case I say cool live your life
your own way but don't live mine and if
we're both good with it then there are
no problems and so that's where I feel
like a lot of people get off-roaded
because they adopt someone else's
preferences and ascribe good or bad
meaning to their own circumstance and
then say we need to change something or
my girlfriend gets a date night every
Thursday why don't we have a date night
every Thursday because now the fact that
we don't have one is bad right whereas
you they might just be in lockstep and
totally fine and so for us it's as long
as there's no discrepancy
um we're usually good and like if
there's a time where Layla's like hey
then I'm like well like I'll stop right
now if I'm like if I'm not you know
doing something but sometimes she's like
hey do you got a minute I'm like I'm in
the middle of this book chapter I'm
gonna need another four hours she's like
cool no sweat like do your thing I'm
gonna go for a walk or whatever you know
what I think the biggest thing is it's
like the biggest gift that we've given
ourselves our relationship we do not
compared to anybody else's like like to
a degree that I've never even had the
thought about somebody else's
relationship and how it contrasts to
mine
because I think it's just like each
relationship is its own unique it's like
a unique organism like it shouldn't be
compared to anything else their Dynamics
yeah and so I think we're two unique
people therefore we have a unique
relationship therefore why would I
compare it to anybody else's I think
that's where most of like The Angst and
the resentment in so many relationships
come from is you're comparing to
somebody else's which they're two
completely different unique people in
different circumstances different life
goals different Mission different values
different interests so it's like why
would I describe their preferences to my
reality how do you fight against that
because I feel like it's a natural uh
Instinct almost to want to compare
yourself to somebody else this is I
think this is a little bit of the
personal development side like we were
so hardcore about that like not
comparing to other people that like I
think that's almost something that like
early on in our relationship one of the
reasons I liked Layla and I kept saying
this early on was I was like I was like
you see reality the way I see reality
and I just didn't have many people who
saw the world the way I saw the world
which is why I felt very lonely for a
lot of my life I just felt like
it just I just you know I missed I would
stay in bed at night and just be like
it's just me like no one else sees it
this way and so I feel like she saw the
world the same way and so you know if
someone else you know is like oh that's
so unhealthy we like we'll both
immediately catch that we're like we're
like okay this [ __ ] yeah
you I mean we both see it when people
are judging us and I think I don't know
it's not even it doesn't even cross my
mind I don't compare myself to other
people in general so it's like I compare
myself to who I know I am potentially
able to be and I think Alex is the same
thing and so it's like our relationship
would make less sense to compare you
know and even you know people say like
relationship relationship goals like
they say that of other people like
I have never said that word I thought
you know what I mean and so like to a
certain degree and like we get some of
that and I'm flattered for those people
but like at the same time I feel like
your relationship goal should be like
who you want to be and how you want that
Dynamic to be whatever way you choose
and zero outside influence on that like
if your parents are like this is weird
then it's like cool weird for you that's
your preference not mine thank God
you're not married to me you know what I
mean like and that's okay and so like we
even we've gotten a row with a family
member they're like
you guys are just so unbalanced I would
never like want your life and I was like
right you don't have it everyone wants
to judge other people and label things
as good or bad and we just don't
subscribe to that it's like there's a
lot of things that people would look at
our marriage like very unhealthy very
bad and I'm like cool [ __ ] off I don't
give a [ __ ] you know I mean like I like
it he likes it yeah it doesn't matter
you're not in our relationship why do
you care yeah what happens is a lot of
people see a relationship
compared to theirs and then either feel
bad about theirs or they feel bad about
theirs and take the next step and then
criticize the other one because it means
they're that must be wrong because I
don't because my ego can't take this
when your ego should just not be
involved at all like if I see a
relationship people are together and
they like each other I'm like awesome
like
so happy like it's thought yeah it's
like the thought doesn't even cross my
mind I mean like genuinely like I don't
care what anyone else does and so like
when someone puts it on us I'm like
cool like thank you you don't have kids
how's that something must be super
[ __ ] up it's like no we just don't
want them right now like what do you
give a [ __ ] yeah thank you for the
irrelevant commentary that describes
something that I describe no meaning to
yeah yeah and how developed do you think
your own character and value system and
and personality need to be developed
before you're ready to date and marry
someone or do you think that you go in
kind of you know a scribbles on a blanks
yeah slate or whatever and then you get
into this relationship and then the
other person builds your values and
character and stuff like that I think
you got to be good being alone you think
you need to be already kind of
understanding yourself
like if you if you're the person who
always has to have somebody there to
like Feel Complete
what you want in my opinion is two whole
people
that together like the sum of two holes
is significantly greater not two halves
making one hole I think it's like I want
at least this is Alex's Viewpoint of the
world yeah well I think we choose what
we are dependent on each other for right
like there there's a lot of stuff I
depend on Alex for and there's a lot of
stuff he depends on me for but it's
chosen we could do it on our own if we
didn't have each other you know what I
mean versus there's some people it's not
chosen it's like necessary and I think
that's when you have issues yeah that
makes sense it makes it seem much more
voluntary than just like feeling
compelled to join a relationship because
of something you need from the other
person 100 it's like I mean this is a
voluntary you know these are voluntary
relationships like and we want to set
ourselves up for Success which is like
don't
need anything yeah can you imagine
something like more beautiful than two
people who don't need one another who
just choose to be with the other because
they prefer life together like that in
my mind is like and if you continue to
prefer living life together then you
don't need
any outside anything but wouldn't you
say that also takes a lot of dating
experience to know what to look for and
what you like and what you don't like I
think dating experience or education you
know what I mean I think like for me
like I read Tony Robbins was it
Unleashed to power within yeah and they
had the whole thing where you write down
yeah awaken the giant I don't even know
what that's it which one it was right
yeah but it was like write down
everything non-negotiables of what you
would break up with someone for and then
the characteristics here look at this
whole thing I had this whole exercise
and like I didn't know I didn't have a
ton of experience like in in depth I
mean you know I had good significant
relationships like whatever you're young
right I'm like 20 something
um but I had read that book and I was
like I trust that this person knows what
he's talking about he's seen enough
relationships if I do this formula I
feel like it will pan out and when we
were talking about getting married I was
like listen this I remember thinking I
was like Tony Robbins said that if you
do X Y and Z you know you you pick like
this which we did and then you go like
this and like you can work on pretty
much everything else as long as you get
the fundamentals right like basically
get the fundamentals right of like
matching your expectations and
non-negotiables of what you're looking
for in a spouse and then everything else
you can create one of the things that I
think has been really important for
Layla and I at least uh so Warren
Buffett was in front of a crowd of
college kids and they and he said so who
here you know I get asked all the time
what if you could only have one
character truth that you would look for
in a spouse what would you look for
right and people were like brains and
beauty or character loyalty right he's
like you don't want any of that stuff
he's like you know what you want low
expectations he's like that's how you
create a marriage that lasts and like he
was being incredibly serious but also
tongue-in-cheek at the same time but I
think part of that process at least how
we approached it was that we were
probably the least Hollywood version of
a relationship you know what I mean like
we unhollywood everything it was very
much like does this make sense right and
I think because of that approach big
picture
neither of us came in expecting the
other person to save us you know what I
mean like I don't need you to make me
happy and I think that's where the whole
person comes in like if you're if you're
like I'm happy doing what I'm doing like
I I don't need you I prefer it but like
I can continue to live my life and the
other person can too then the
expectations are significantly lower
from the other person which is why like
this is again me talking for me like the
fact that Layla never tried to change me
and still hasn't throughout our whole
relationship I think it's one of the
biggest reasons why like you've been
good because like I resist anyone who
tries to change me very hard like her
Point earlier about like no rules
like I hate rules like tell me I can't
do something like there's like there's
nothing that drives me more mad than
something like that and so
because this may come like what if
circumstances change what you know what
I mean like I hate it and so low
expectations and leading from values has
been how we've just used as our compass
pointing true north of mission and then
like we accept the waxes and wanes that
occur during the natural shifts of time
and it's I don't know yeah and I think
it's not judging at relationships morph
and change and wax and Wayne like you're
saying like a lot of people judge that
they're like oh we're not feeling as
close like this is a problem if if we're
not feeling as close I wouldn't label
that as a problem I'd be like that's
normal in relationships or if somebody's
like I've been dating her for two years
now I'm not feeling as attracted I'm
like makes sense you basically her
roommate now let's work on it you know
so I think a lot of the things that
people label as problems and
relationships are normal parts of being
in a relationship and they're just
things you have to manage they're not
things you have to fix and I think
that's the difference is like we don't
look at any part of our relationship as
well as like anything that needs to be
fixed because it's not broken and so I
wouldn't use that word hurt it's like
things that we have to manage and
usually you're like a couple tiny tweaks
away from anything and so
and when you don't need the other person
it makes all those things feel much less
serious yeah they're way less like high
there's there's way less pressure you
know what I mean it's like I don't need
you it's like hey when you do this I
feel like if we did this it'd be a
little better does that work for you
yeah great fantastic you know what I
mean like it's just thousands of those
there's also low stakes because if that
person doesn't want to comply they're
like
okay cool it's fine are you guys
comfortable saying the last direct
example of a disagreement that you guys
had and then how you resolved that so to
give the viewers an actual like case
right here this is what happened and
this is how it was solved
I think the only thing we argue about is
business stuff no yeah nothing personal
it's not we don't because that's not
that important it's not that it's not
important it's just we don't have many
disagreements we both are really aligned
on it so
I think it's that and we both
just have we spend much more time in the
business so there's more time to happen
Okay
um probably cash cows yeah so
um yeah we were thinking about starting
a show putting a lot of like effort and
money into something called Cash cows I
really wanted to do it Layla was like we
have too much on our plate right now and
so and to be fair that's kind of like a
recurring theme so that would be like
the most recent one that has come up but
it's one of many well I think there's it
was looking at a way that basically it
was a show that we would you know people
would pay to be on the show basically
kind of like a shark tank type thing
um they pay in equity like we get a
person because that's how shark tank
works they get they get a stake in the
in the business
um to be on the show to be on it yeah
yeah no I thought Kevin O'Leary or it
was um Mark Cuban argued against that
it's been that way not anymore anybody
that goes on for years okay they got a
state because people would get on the
show not take any bids and then their
business would blow up so yeah plus
whatever Deals they take wow I had no
idea that was the case so that was the
idea and
I was against it because I thought one
it relies on you and me and I also know
Alex doesn't like doing the same thing
over and over again so it worries me
because I was like I could see in two
years you don't want or even in a year
you don't want to do this show yeah and
it requires our time which I don't like
building something knowing it's going to
require our time
and so we disagreed yeah so we disagreed
and basically we'll just keep revisiting
and I'll you know like she'll bring up
concerns she has and I'll it's more like
she's like here are the problems with
the thing that I see and like unless I'm
like no I don't think I'm gonna get sick
of anything ever like did you did you
guys did you have a resolution on cash
cow or no
okay yeah we can't put the different
idea yeah we have a different a
different thing you share it no not yet
but for advertising it is free it's not
we're not going to take a stake in it
like a shark tank
but I think it has that the
conversations often go like here's the
reasons why I don't support the idea
yeah and then I go back and then I give
Alex space because I mean I do think
it's also like something that you have
to understand if you're working with
somebody like Alice is very much like
the vision is like continuing to bombard
him like I need to give him some space
to like digest it and like I'm sure it
sucks because like coming up with an
idea next sharing that idea with a bunch
of people it's like you're very
vulnerable it's like a very it's a
vulnerable state I would imagine and so
it's like I try to give him the feedback
and then like kind of distance for a
little bit and then we revisit maybe the
next day yeah and even after you came to
that initial resolution of like okay you
know maybe we aren't going to proceed
with this part of you I'm sure still
kind of wanted to do it but then that
got squashed over time once you realize
this is not happening honestly I don't
have a desire to do it because like we
just continue to beat the idea up and
then like really like it's one of the
things we say let's like play it out
like let's play it out right like well
then what happens then what happens then
like let's talk six moves future like
what happens and so
um the more we beat it up the more we
played it out I was like I think like
these are the points she's bringing up
are irreconcilable because like I always
get excited about all the upside I'm
like man this could be like a cool new
version of Shark Tank it'd be exciting
we get to you know we get so many
messages from smaller businesses that we
would never normally like work with
because most of our companies are you
know 10 million plus uh Top Line that
like
you know like it's
it doesn't make sense but I want to help
and so I was like okay if I could help a
few people in an intermittent setting
and then broadcast it then it can help a
lot of other people it doesn't make
sense time wise the commitment amount of
you know do you have to build a studio
do we have to build a production team
like how how you know played out right
and so after we really played out every
angle of it because I'll come with like
a three-quarter idea right I'm like I
know you know I took two or three steps
let's talk because I'm not going to take
20 because I don't want to do like
talking you know it's a free-flowing
thing
um and so
once it's resolved you don't really come
back to it so like I'm I have no like
the points that were brought up
made sense and there are better you
there are better uses for our assets and
resources so like if you think about
strategy big picture yeah the definition
of strategy as I Define it is how you
choose to allocate limited resources
against unlimited options
and so
I'm saying we have these resources this
is an option I think we should allocate
it towards this is this is my strategy
right and then she will say
I don't think it's a good resource
allocation because of either opportunity
cost or something else we could pursue
or the cost is too high in inherently in
this thing based on the upside we
predict right and so either disagree on
the cost or we'll disagree on the upside
or both right or door three that there's
an alternative that would be a better
return than than the primary scenario so
those are kind of like three variables
that we'll think through when we're
beating up a decision and so once once
that's spelled out like I have a full
loop on that like that Loop's closed and
we we pivoted like 20 other versions of
something like that to what we have you
know that what we think we're going to
do
um and then there's timeline it's like
okay cool we'll agreed on this when and
then we'll have to talk that out it's
like well resources right now are
constrained you know based on growth it
might be a two quarters or nothing and
then two quarters now we revisit and if
we're not ready
it might be two quarters from then you
know what I mean yeah and that's
something that I've had to learn because
I tend to be more like go go bowling
china shop like ask questions later
we'll figure it out yeah
um and Layla sends me more calculated
and so it's I mean that's our yin and
yang and that's why it's either one's
right or wrong like like it has just
worked well for us to have that
drawbridge tension uh between the
extremes and that's where I think the
magic happens for us what's the
motivation right now for you to continue
pushing forward in in terms of business
and continuing to grow and where is that
coming from
I can say mine I mean all right why
don't you why don't you go oh
you seemed eager
um yeah I think motivation in business
it just continues to be
wanting to have an impact like I know
that sounds so cheesy but I was like
really thinking about it like when I met
Alex he was like what do you want to do
I was like I just really want to help
people and I remember he looked at me
he's like could you make money too you
know and so I think looking at how can
we utilize like we have an insane team
we have like tons of access to talent
and to companies that are amazing how
can we best put together this stack of
resources to have the biggest impact
possible that's really what I look at in
terms of the kind of workplace we build
like we get to set new standards for
like what makes sense in the workplace
like for example like we pay really well
and we don't have to
um and outside the workplace which is
like how people build companies like the
way they think about building companies
like we're changing the way that people
think about how they make money how they
make a living how they build their
companies
um and I think
knowing that if we continue to do this
for long enough we will get to a point
where we're so good that we can have an
impact even sooner in that life cycle
you know what I mean like we've talked
about like be able to build a school for
entrepreneurship and things like that
because I think what we both genuinely
really enjoy doing is teaching that
stuff it's like teaching people the
lessons that we have learned that we
paid a lot in terms of pain or time or
money to learn in a way that is
digestible easy to learn and they can go
you know take action on it immediately
like I think that's always what we want
to do and so the motivation is just to
do more of that like I want to like
right now I'm motivated to continue
hiring these people so I can get above a
little bit of the business so that I can
spend more time making content because
like I barely put any thought into it
you know what I mean and I want to get
better at it because I want to be a
better teacher
um
so yeah I know it's it's always just
being better being a better version of
myself like being a better contributor
so I mean the mission of the business is
to make real business knowledge
available to everyone and so that's the
mission of acquisition.com and you know
my my self-worth measuring stick over
the last
year or so has begun to shift internally
for me because everything so I think
every day we wake up and we ask a
question and we spend our day trying to
answer it right so for me for most of my
adult life as a business person it's
been waking up and thinking like how do
I make more money which shifted later to
how do I will this increase my net worth
how can I increase my net worth like
that that is like how it shifted today
it's
will this be build Goodwill
and I think that that's been one of the
more internal shifts that's been
occurring and it's still continuing to
happen with me is that like the net
worth stick is is dropping and the
Goodwill stick or brand Equity stick is
is rising and so what happens is like if
you change the question that you ask
yourself every day then it changes the
lens through which you interpret reality
and the decisions that you make and so
my weighing my measuring stick is has
shifted and so
if you think about like the richest man
in the world like if because you if you
take the net the the net worth thing to
its natural conclusion it's like I want
to be the richest man in the world and
then I thought about it I was like do I
really want that because then the
follow-up question is when because no
one's richest man in the world forever
right it's only like a very brief
distinctive time and then they they go
down right and I was like well that's
kind of a weird goal and I also think
that if if again you take it all the way
out that means that the day I die right
I would have no Goodwill left no brand
Equity left because I would have
extracted all of the value from every
relationship possible if that's what I'm
truly maximizing for and when I thought
about that I was like
that's not the person I want to be and
that's not what the end of my life what
I want the end of my life to look like
and so then I was like all right well
what do I want the end of my life to
look like and I was like well I want to
have
I would like to have I would like to die
with nothing left to give and so if
that's how I want to die then I have to
start changing How I Live Now in order
to get that now obviously a portion of
it for sure we want to continue to you
know make more money build build really
big businesses that we have more ability
to do cool stuff right
um but we're now measuring it against a
different stick which is like will this
build the brand will this help more
people will this build Goodwill nope you
build Goodwill you make money for sure
but for me that fundamental shift has
been
a cooler internal fire because at a
certain point
there's no the marginal impact of of
money decreases precipitously as you
gain more of it and so but the the
marginal return on Goodwill and brand
Equity continues to compound like the
amount of people that stop us in the
street every day being like dude watch
your stuff like I went from I quit my
job and now we make two million dollars
a year like it happens literally every
day and like that's cool and that's why
we do it and that's why the mission of
the business to make real business
education available to everyone and so
everything that we're doing now is
oriented towards that like me writing a
book takes like this next book that's
going to come out 100 million dollar
leads
um it'll probably take me by the time
it's published about 1300 hours
and I'm gonna give away for 99 cents
there's very little direct Roi that it
makes sense for me to do that like for
1300 hours like just like in terms of
what people offer me every day for my
time is usually between 25 and 50 000 an
hour if I'm gonna like work with them on
something business-wise which I don't
because we only do Equity but like
whatever and so if I think about that
like okay well 25 000 times a thousand
is 25 million so I put 25 million
dollars of what I probably could have
spent time on directly into this book
that I'm gonna give away for 99 cents
but if I'm using the net worth stick it
would it would be a failure and I should
do other stuff that I would get a better
return on my time on but in terms of the
Goodwill and the amount of people that
it will reach with no extra extra
incremental unit of time
there are few that are better and it
will outlive me YouTube videos will not
outlive me a book will
and so when I think about that long term
like that's when I'm on my deathbed
having nothing left to give I want to
extract everything I can out of my head
put it there so that anyone can consume
it like I get people I get messages from
like India and Bangladesh you know
people be like thank you for making it
99 Cents because we could afford it now
here's a question if it's just Goodwill
why charge 99 Cents why not just it's
because you have to put it on the on
Just for Amazon to push it because if
they make so 66 cents of it goes to
Amazon
I'm not getting rich on 33 seconds yeah
um but when they make money they they
push it more so it sells like right now
it sells like the other book sells I
think 20 like I just checked it's like
22 or 23 000 copies a month
with nothing like just word of mouth and
Amazon pushing it and so like that's 23
000 people every month that get have
access to stuff and learn stuff and make
more money and I get messages every day
from it and so it's like that's because
like she knows like when I'm in the
thick of writing the book I'm like like
you know I mean it's tough like it's
easy to write a book it's very hard to
write a book what's what's your process
like for writing a book
like how do you where do you even start
I feel like I would be so overwhelmed
and and constantly doubting like is this
going to be good enough because I'm
actually going to read it for sure
all those thoughts how do you how do you
push yourself outside of that yeah well
I mean for the book I start with what
job do I want the book to do right like
what do I want it to do and so this book
100 million dollar leads is when
someone's like man I have this thing I
can't get anybody to sell it to I want
somebody like you need to read 100
million dollar leads like that's where
it fits in the conversation like I need
any more leads like right by 100 leads
you know go read it and then I start
with that as the very narrowly defined
problem and then I try and think how can
I in as few moves as possible solve this
for as many people as possible and
that's very hard especially with that
topic
um like that book was significantly
harder to write than offers right
because offers is really super well
defined like what do you do in exchange
for money like it's a clear problem
definition this one's like how do you
get anyone to know about anything
it's really what it is it's advertising
right and so anyways start with the
problem and I work backwards and then I
I spent I've made 127 different models
of what I thought like the core model of
the book would be like you're familiar
with the value in the first book there's
something called the value equation
which kind of the core concept of the
book which a lot of people shared and
whatnot and so within this book
um there were two core Core Concepts
that I had to like pull out of hundreds
of iterations to get it right and so the
first probably like eight nine months of
the book is like really just drawing out
models over and over again and then
beating them up and so uh Dr Kashi who's
my co-writer
um on this like we'll we'll meet every
Monday and we'll beat it up for two
hours I'm like what about this and then
we just try another scenario and try and
break the model until eventually we
can't break it and then once we have the
core models of the book then I'll start
writing the book and so right now once I
do it I have like this is the 12th draft
of the book
um I mean and if you think about it the
way that you put time into YouTube
videos like the reason that most books
don't sell a lot is because they're not
that good or there's an alternative
agenda right if you're making the book
with the intention of like how can I get
somebody who doesn't have clients or
doesn't have customers to get their
first customers and they know nothing
right and then I also have somebody
who's doing 10 million a month and I
need and I want it to provide value to
that guy how do I solve both of those
and do it in under 200 Pages keeping it
under a third grade reading level
that's what takes time and so that's so
it was 650 Pages that's got cut down to
about 220.
I honestly never want to write a book
watch it and write one it looks awful
but a lot of times what would you say
the most challenging part is
foreign
getting the concepts right the models
like the reason the value equation
hasn't been like altered and people
share it all over the place but no one
changes it it's because it's right
like if you see people who like come up
with these acronyms or like little you
know like people trying to teach
something and they'll spin something
together and they'll throw it on the
wall and people will continue to alter
it is because it so the quality of a
model is based on validity and utility
so how how true is it is it does it
predict an outcome and
um is it sorry is it is it useful and is
it valid so like I could say something's
right some things are wrong that's a
model for outcomes but is it useful no
right and so if you have something that
predicts an outcome and is viable in
many many many situations you have a
very valuable model if you have a model
that only applies to these situations
and is wrong in all these other ones
it's not that useful and so if I want to
create very useful models that are
correct in many scenarios I have to
continue to re-chunk and rework it and
when you look in retrospect like if you
see the models to be like oh of course
these make sense but they're unbreakable
and that's why it's so hard because once
you see them it seems obvious but it
took me a lot of it operations to get
there that is by far the hardest part of
it writing the book for me writing is
not as as difficult that's more like
coats of paint and polishing it over and
over again but the idea is the hard part
the timeline you have to finish by no
just keeps going until it's done and
it's done I like and I I feel like now
this is the third book that I have
finished I'm like it's it's going to be
wrapped up in the next 14 days it'll be
done
um I know that I'm done when I'm sick of
the book and I don't want to look at it
anymore and I'm like I don't even care
like it is it is exact like there's
there's nothing I can change about it
like if they don't like it then it is
what it is but like there's nothing else
I can change about it that would add or
detract from the concept of the book at
that point then it's been
like there's nothing else and then then
like you can go in the world and maybe
it takes less time maybe it takes more
it takes what it takes
I'll have that
can we walk through maybe each of your
own respective daily schedules and maybe
like how you can divide up that time
between work if you're writing every day
and then at the end of the night you
know how you guys hang out
sure
um we're a little different so I mean
wake up and
I guess drink decaf coffee right now
because I haven't been drinking calf so
there you go I don't know I feel like
sometimes it makes me look a little too
buzzed if that makes sense a little too
wired yeah and I don't really need any
more of that I have to play that
naturally so what time do you guys wake
up at is it still yeah it's so funny
everyone's always like when you wake up
and go to bed I don't pay attention why
really it's just no alarm just you wake
up yeah I don't have alarms for you okay
if we have something going on like an
event or something sure I'll set an
alarm but like I mean I'll wake up
anytime between
5 30 and 6 usually okay that's like
pretty average for me
um and then
wake up uh drink coffee usually
first thing I do is open my laptop
start doing emails in Asana and slack so
I like take care of everything that's
come in the night in Asana oh no no no I
don't know
I'm actually I'm literally thinking as
I'm saying it's like God this is boring
here we go most riveting part of the
interview biggest drop off on YouTube
um
uh asanas lack all that stuff and then I
usually work on something for like a
couple hours like probably two to three
hours I work on either like an
initiative doing diligence on a company
working on a company initiative uh
building on training doing content
whatever it is working on it for a few
hours and then usually around like 9 30
or 9 yeah uh go to the gym work out come
back uh shower at some point I try to
like delay as long as possible sometimes
I don't even depending on the meetings
we have they're all internal like you're
not getting a shower
um if they're external like with our
portfolio CEOs and stuff like definitely
going to
um and then do meetings from anywhere
from like 11 to 5 typically and then or
you know the days I prefer it's like 12
to 5 or something like that
then done with meetings Alex and I go on
a walk we debrief with each other uh
then we usually go to dinner somewhere
really easy where we like pick up
something
um
and then we come back lately sometimes
been working again at night for a little
bit just because of like the load of
things going on
um and then
read or watch something on YouTube or
watch a show and go to bed what do you
watch on YouTube
honestly I just study different people's
channels now so like I was on the last
time I was on here and I was like I
haven't watched anything I was like [ __ ]
I should watch this [ __ ]
um and I'm like oh wow like I get why
I'm like I just I get it
um and I'm like I could put so much more
effort into this uh just seeing what
people do so just the biggest channels I
can find I look at I look at a lot of
the creative channels like Mr Beast or
arak or like them yeah yeah because I
think how can you take that and apply it
to like educating people on business
like there are principles you can take
away and so I'd rather look at that
because I don't really like to watch
other people's business content because
I don't like a lot of it or I don't want
to like assimilate other people's ideas
so I try not to watch any other channels
of that
but that's usually that's my routine
yeah I have a more
um like I have a bigger window so I'll
wake up between like 3 30 and 7. so it
really just depends on when I wake up I
haven't I can't remember the last time
we set an alarm
um just wake up when I wake up you would
wake up naturally at three o'clock in
the morning oh yeah really oh yeah for
sure do you feel tired or you just oh
good today at like 4 30. I mean yeah I
mean that's I mean that's not really
just saying like that's a yeah it's a
Saturday if Alex is writing a book or
has ideas he'll wake up like it's the
idea that wakes me up so yeah it'll
knock on the door and I'm like oh I'm up
all right so and yeah so I'll wake up
and then um it depends on if Layla's up
or not if Layla's up
um then I'll have coffee with her and
then I'll start working and if she's not
up then I'll
not have coffee with her I'll just have
coffee alone but straight on my just
straight to my desk and start working
there and then I I work sometimes I go
to the gym sometimes I don't
um usually I do all my creative work in
the beginning of the day so
um book stuff content stuff
um Creative Solutions for like portfolio
companies like if they need
you know sales scripts like looked at or
like there's marketing materials or
something like that I'll take a look at
it that's not as often now it's much
more like probably candidates and stuff
like if we're looking to hire a
marketing like a director of marketing
for a company it's like oh look at their
their resume I'll click you know I'll
just do research background
um but then uh but then yeah the second
half the day is meetings for me and then
I have the same back half as Layla so
for me it's just wake up first half is
is solo work second half is group work
and that is that has worked extremely
well for me just no disruptions first
half of my day is mine second half is
meetings and that's worked yeah have you
ever had a desire to travel
oh we do travel yeah how often this is
just like what we do on a normal
um we were traveling a lot until about
seven weeks ago when we decided to
cancel all speaking most speaking aside
from certains that we committed to
um
and not do that anymore yeah wine is
speaking
forever it's a season thing one and then
two it's like we want to make sure that
we're on the stages that we want to be
on I think you know in the beginning it
was more like sure well like hey like
when's this date like yeah we'll try and
make it you know um and we ended up just
getting pulled in too many directions
and then yeah and then our faces were
like plaster all over stuff I noticed
that yeah and I don't have seen quite a
few things where your face was the very
first one and everyone was reposting
yeah and uh I think I was asked to speak
at something similar yeah I'm just I'm
not I think it's gross yeah okay like I
I've thrown multiple events myself and I
would never exploit speakers like that
and so experiencing it sucks
um but it makes you appreciate the
people that throw good events you know
what I mean and we want to preserve our
energy for people that are looking to
throw events for the right reasons and
not and looking to treat the speakers
well you know what I mean I think that
that's important it's a speaker
experience is seriously it's a thing
yeah yeah
um yeah so I mean the big picture is
like if you just think like time in
versus impact doing shows like this
doing podcasts like I actually prefer
this to the the stage stuff and the
reach that you get is significantly
higher so like per unit of time there's
there's not a strong argument for the
other the only reason we'll do the other
ones is like if it's a state like now it
would have to be a stage that we would
pursue or one that we're like we want to
be excited to get on a stage not just
like passively accept an invitation and
so we we just pretty much drew a line
canceled everything going forward and
then now we're just being far more
selective about the few things that we
take I will say this we talked to two
different people that are far ahead of
us you know like worth billions and I
asked them how they think through
speaking on stages and they both spoke
to the point of
only speak on stages where you would
want people to associate you with every
person that's speaking on that stage
right and that's incredible yeah
yes because I was really struggling with
it because I'm like is this does this
work I want to make an impact and help
these people in the heart yeah I want to
help these people but you know but can I
help those people if I'm then associated
with these other people from there on
out the answer is no so I think that was
a huge piece and I think that it was an
unlocked for me I was like I get it now
so it's like only speak on stages that
you want to be associated with all the
other people speaking there and the
brand of the company or person that
you're speaking on their stage which
means that's a perspective I've never
thought of before yeah because is it
this is the question if you're speaking
on a stage is it building your brand or
theirs right correct and if it's not
building your brand why are you speaking
on the stage if it's deteriorating your
brand if it's almost because some people
you know for us like we don't sell
anything and then we might go on some on
stage and they're milking our brand
they're selling tickets with our face on
it that's detracting from our brand it's
not what I want to do if we threw an
event I'm not going to charge people
that much money for a ticket you know
what I mean so it's like if I wouldn't
even do that myself it's tough to then
watch somebody else do it yeah I've been
invited a lot to speak I've turned
everything down except for one and the
one event it ended up getting pushed but
it was I would love to be associated
with everyone on stage like I'm the odd
one out in in that situation but even
with that they were saying oh you could
sell something on sale like I have
nothing to sell yeah and it seems like
with a lot of these it's like and we'll
let you pitch for free and you know
we're not gonna ask for anything but you
know we want you to come and just speak
yeah so when you don't have anything to
sell especially uh or any hard pitches
like that on stage it doesn't make sense
yeah plus I've always thought about it
logically that if I want to reach a
hundred thousand people I'd much rather
it's so much easier to turn on the
camera then go up on stage and travel
and have to wait and it's just because
it's two days I don't like it it's two
days and then I think to myself
opportunity cost of two days financially
never makes sense yeah from uh even just
if we just go impact stamp point if I
spend two days recording you know
scripting and recording content or like
writing out bullets of things that I
want to cover and like really spend time
on it there's no universe or that and
especially because we've now that we
have the reach that we have there's no
universe that doesn't reach more people
than any event and so
that's where you know what I mean like
to your point
if we're really proud to associate with
the brand and the other people on stage
and it's a stage that we would actively
pursue and be excited about then that's
what we're saying yes to everything else
is I'll just say put it this way like
stages we own so we can control the
setting and we know that our messages
are being delivered the way we want them
to be delivered because to your point
like if I'm not selling anything using
my face you better not be saying
something using my face you know what I
mean right and some of it though I've
seen the costs associated with holding
these meetings I mean fifty a hundred
thousand I Patrick Bet David did one how
much was that Jack three million dollars
to host the event for him yeah so and
and he does that every single year but
there's so much work that goes behind
the scenes to to orchestrate something
like that yeah I think because he knows
how to do it right yeah you know he's
had probably a decade of experience just
hosting that event yeah he's got it down
it's still three million dollars in
weeks worth of prep totally just to set
up so cool yeah yeah our first our like
the biggest like we did a delivery event
so there was no like it was just like an
event we didn't sell anything it was
just for 1.7 million it's like it just
costs a lot because we fed everybody for
two days it's like having extra protein
yeah it's like having six White House
you know I mean it's like having six
weddings may as well just double on a
wedding on that yeah
while you guys are here yeah yeah
I have a philosophical question what do
you guys think is the biggest threat to
humanity right now
it's a deep question man I was thinking
about it this morning
so when you've got like the impending
you know tension with the East and
nuclear or whatever if something
escalated and whatnot
um that's one the other one is just it's
just AI you know I mean it would just
like I saw um a video two days ago that
was an entire video of a girl like
dancing and doing all this stuff and
like they're like this person isn't real
and I think that that has really really
deep implications like AI will only be a
threat to humanity if it doesn't want
Humanity to be here right like that's
that's where it's a threat otherwise I
think there's like the micro or much
more soon threat of what are people
gonna do because like even content right
like imagine you've got somebody who can
crank perfect content every hour of
every day
making 100 videos every day that are
like perfectly optimized and doesn't
sleep and every time people watch they
learn and they can pull from every
YouTube video that's ever been made like
that's I have a point I want to mention
yeah this is crazy Ali abdall on Twitter
posted his I think it was like 10
productivity hacks and I went through it
I loved it I thought this was one of his
best posts he's ever made yeah and he
came out a week later to say that AI
wrote that he had nothing to do with it
and it was also one of his most liked
and retweeted tweets it was AI I was
blown away and he said it was a part of
this experiment that he was running to
see if an AI would be able to replace a
human and the answer was yes and better
yeah yeah and that is nuts to me and I
remember reading this specifically and
by like wow this is really good really
insightful yeah I loved it and I I read
it a few times because it's that good
but it was Ai and it just pulled the
data from the internet and then
assimilated it in such a way that people
understood it's incredible if you
there's AI stuff right now for like if
you just say like hey I want a guy
smoking a cigar looking over a city in
Van Gogh thing you click a button and
they have a randomly generated and just
click generate again to enter it again
and now map these the Confluence of
these things you've got AI that can
write better than humans and then you've
got it making moving pictures in real
time it's like it will be able to script
and animate in real time perfect content
and so that's where like it's going to
be really interesting from like so like
imagine movies in Hollywood like they
can crank out a million movies with a
click of a button like it's just not
that far away and so it's just going to
be like what what jobs will be left for
people to do
it's going to be like and I think a lot
of AI stuff people haven't been afraid
of it because the people Empower their
jobs were never at risk yeah and so it's
just been laborers so like laborers like
drivers like truck drivers are going to
be which is a huge huge amount of the
workforce for men especially drivers in
general Uber like truck drivers Etc like
they're just going to be replaced right
like that's like super like everyone but
those already exist don't you think that
would lead to more productivity in
general because there's something that
is farming farming equipment I mean has
taken away the job so many people but
that's allowed us to progress so much
I'm not like believe me I'm Pro
technology in general I think we're
where a machine can do everything better
than a human
that's where it gets it gets fuzzy
that's where it gets tough yeah I can't
did already to a certain degree in terms
of Just Cars Machinery uh digging I
think it's the it's building things
coming together it's like you have these
robots that you see Boston uh Dynamics
yeah Boston Dynamics have those crazy
robots and then you merge that with like
the brain that like can learn and then
just replace all physical labor oh now
because it's really expensive to buy
those versus labor but then in 40
machine Generations it'll be cheaper and
they can replace them like that and then
when that machine AI can also do X you
know what I mean like and they just
become more and more able
um and there's a saying in the finance
world you probably know but like things
take longer to happen uh than you think
and then faster than you can imagine so
it's like it takes longer for you know
like in The Big Short like they knew
that it was upside down for four years
before it actually happened right and
then it happened almost overnight and I
feel like it's going to be the same
thing with with AI stuff not to get uh
but it's something that it definitely
keeps me up whenever I go down the
rabbit hole and I see the stuff that's
advancing in the rate that it's
advancing right now and how it implies
like
like every single copywriter every
content creator like that's just don't
you think then it would be so optimized
that then you'll need outliers to stand
out from that so it'll constantly have
to be fighting against itself
because if everything is optimized then
nothing is and then you have to do
something else you would be competing
against itself right it would just be
but like it's AI convenience itself not
against us like we're just
we're not in the arms race sure like
it'll get sad yeah right like it'll just
be way above us and we're just never
gonna be able to make stuff as good
that's where it gets frightening so
anyways that's what I think the biggest
Community is great answer all right
Layla not just similar
um I think it's the Next Generation
honestly
so I was listening to I can't remember
which podcast it was and they were
talking about how the upcoming
generation that will be the ones in
power very soon right
um nobody in the history of mankind has
ever lied down as many hours a day as
they do
and so I think it's actually like the
dissolution of the Next Generation
because I think that like AI for example
if in the right hands with the right
regulations in place I think could be
beneficial to humanity but I think that
what like the underlying issue is that
the people that are coming into power
and like the Next Generation don't look
at it that way or aren't going to take
the measures needed to make sure that it
doesn't go to the extreme that it could
does that make sense so I think it's
more that's what I fear because I see it
in like
there's I mean and listen this is a huge
generalization but because there's tons
of people still in the upcoming
generation that are super hard working
super diligent like absolutely out there
killing it like I talk to them every day
they work on my team but there's also a
ton of people who I've never seen like
more glued to their phones more like
lazy not wanting to work not wanting to
do anything and that makes me sad you
know I mean it just it just sucks I
can't imagine that's a happy life and so
I just wonder what's going to happen
when all these things are presented to
humanity and those are the people making
decisions and deciding who's in power in
this world
so that's what I think about
I agree with that I think the next
generation is going to be could be a
very big inflection point just for
Humanity in general I think I also think
it's more of a symptom though than of
like life for a lot of people it's just
gotten extremely easy like everyone has
a microwave now well not everyone I
shouldn't say that a vast vast majority
of people have a microwave now whereas I
don't know how long ago right let's say
100 or so years ago like it was it was
pretty rare you know
100 years
I'm just saying okay only a few people
okay but you know what I'm saying like
stuff like that it's everything is
accessible to everybody nowadays I know
and I
I think it'll take a turn uh but he is
history shows that it always does but
it's just it's hard to watch it's hard
to talk to people that think that way
and it's hard to talk to people who you
know I mean I've had conversations with
plenty of people that are like straight
out of college with no experience or
skills and they're like you need to pay
me a hundred thousand dollars I'm like
for what
like you didn't do anything I think it's
more expectations around reality
um but you know I think every incumbent
generation always has gripes with the
you know the the upcoming one like
that's the 60s the 70s like you know
it's you know there's there's always
been
um Strife but you know we'll see I mean
the thing is a lot of the stuff is
Uncharted Territory in terms of how
technology has shifted the landscape and
really media in general
um how much that has like the propaganda
machine you know what I mean yes in
terms of Shifting shifting culture in
real time
um that's the stuff that's I don't know
scarier or different than so like the
ability to shift the entire Zeitgeist of
an era through media was not possible
before and so I think what happens is
right now is that the extremes are
significantly more
things are more polarized and it's kind
of I think there's a word for it but
it's like a double gaussian chart you
know but like they're it's way more
polar yes that's what we'll see and I
think to your point about like
or what you were saying about threats
it's like world wars like this crazy
divide you know we'll see but I mean I
think there's big Cycles in humanity and
what happens after war is peace and so
hopefully we can avoid it but
um anyways those are the things that
keep me up besides AI
in this generation like if you look at
like creators even on YouTube that I
look at like that the upcoming
generation has such an opportunity and
like the one like to get on there and
like change how people are thinking I'm
just we know a few that are but it'd be
cool to see more that was the conclusion
I drew I thought it was the media to be
honest this morning that was just like a
maybe a 30 minute like internal dialogue
though I was just like on my walk and I
was like it was pretty dangerous you
know and especially like with all the
power that they have like over
influencing Americans as well as
politicians that's why they're uh
outlawed in most countries so like most
media social media is not allowed like
Tick Tock that's interesting
well that's also a double-edged sword
it's like I get it you know I get both
sides I'm worried it's more about the
destruction of the planet and the
natural resources and killing off the
oceans and Elon doesn't seem upset about
it or he's not worried about it so he
I've taken my I've taken my lead from
him and then I assume he's done more
work yeah answering that question and so
you know we because we talk about not so
we're back to acquisition
um but like for me at acquisition
our our goals like to make real business
uh education available to everybody and
it's it's not because we think that
we're going to save the world but we
hope that we can equip whoever can cure
Alzheimer's and whoever can build a
for-profit business that cleans the
ocean like we want to enable that person
too but he wants to colonize Mars so
don't you think that maybe he thinks
that Humanity's too far gone and that's
why he wants to build something else I
think yeah it's actually yeah if at
least all the things that I've heard
it's just much more of a Fail-Safe of
like Humanity's likelihood of staying
alive
increasing significantly if it's a
multi-planetary species like that's the
single like belief point that he has
looking at like the models of sure
population growth and like if an
asteroid hits or like you know I mean
like there's or nuclear like there's
just a lot of things that can happen on
a planet that could kill everybody and
so if there's just two you've got to
back up and that's what significantly
increases the likelihood that the
species stays alive I'm also a Believer
humans one of our best powers is our
ability to adapt and I think we're a lot
better at adapting than mitigating other
issues and like you said if something
happens to the environment I would like
to think some for-profit organization or
whatever could go and try to find a
solution for it I think so yeah I wrote
this down which I think is kind of
interesting uh lots of successful
business people tend to have greater
egos because there is a numerical metric
to their success uh whereas in other
areas of life there is no number such as
like your success in relationships or
something like that
I have noticed that tends to lead like I
said to Greater egos how do you guys
both balance your egos especially in a
relationship where a lot of the times
there usually is someone kind of at the
top and a supporter it's pretty common
but with both of you being so successful
in your respective niches uh how do you
balance the egos I mean it's been tough
I didn't I didn't think that laila's ego
is going to fit in the door but you know
here we are apparently you know she was
able to work doors yeah
go ahead yeah I'll speak for myself
which is like I don't have an ego I tend
to err on the side of insecure so if
anything it's been a balance because
Alex tends to have an ego I tend to be
insecure and I think that we've taught
each other uh
I think that we've learned from each
other
in a way that has helped us each kind of
migrate a little bit more towards the
middle if that makes sense like I tend
to be incredibly self-critical like no
matter how much success I have like I do
not see myself that way like no matter
how fit I am I think I'm fat like well I
remember when I won a bikini competition
I was like no [ __ ] I was like that's
making sense I'm fat they must have felt
bad for me like that's literally how my
brain works and that's how I am with
everything with success it's just like
any amount of money we make I always
look at other people and circumstances
as to being the reason why rather than
myself and so I've had to work on
building my self-esteem through building
evidence that I am good at things
um and showing myself those arguments
because I think my brain tends to go to
why I'm not good at things and why it's
all other people and not myself
um and I've had to work really hard to
build my self-esteem by presenting
myself with undeniable evidence as to
why I'm good at something so
I don't really think I've had like a I I
definitely haven't aired on the side of
having like a big ego
yeah uh hasn't been my uh hasn't been my
fight uh it hasn't been my battle no I
mean my I've been I've been pretty
public about the fact that the thing
that I that I struggle with is ego and
pride and um I mean it's it's the it's
the aspect of myself that I hate the
most you know what I mean
um I'm grateful for the the drive you
know that it that it brings the ambition
and whatnot
um but you know I remember I was talking
to it was like an executive coach a few
years back and I was like how do I keep
the drive without the other stuff like I
was like I feel like it's really
effective fuel I was like but it just
burns dirty
and so
um you know trying to tackle that has
been a lifelong journey and I don't you
know I hope that I I hope that I've I've
gotten better over time and I think that
so something just going back to
something we're talking earlier about
finding a maid I think that
I think that you want to have a mate
that compliments you and has character
traits that you Aspire towards and so
there are many traits that Layla has
that I aspire to be more like and there
are things that I probably have that she
is buyers to me more like and I think in
that way we can both improve and I think
if if you're kind of balanced you end up
kind of meeting a little bit more in the
Middle where like hopefully I will have
less ego she will have more she'll be
less insecure I'll be more insecure you
know what I mean and we just meet in a
place of just kind of acceptance but I
mean managing that is
I guess it's like understanding what
context it's in so it's like is the
context our our romantic relationship
for me that would probably like feeling
disrespected by something that she would
say that would be something where like
my ego might manifest and I might get
angry
um I think that has happened less and
less
um
you know in the business setting it's
the same thing someone not basically
complying with with the request and you
know me getting upset about that but I
think the more times I'm wrong and I've
been wrong plenty of times I try and
remind myself of the times that someone
else was right and I was wrong and to
just like like put some space between my
emotional reaction and my actual
reaction
um so that I can give myself like a
counting five before I like say
something stupid and so
um one of my favorite definitions of
humility is from uh Clayton Christensen
he said humility isn't uh thinking less
of yourself it's increasing your regard
for others and C C S Lewis has a
different definition of it but I also
like it which is
um
humility isn't thinking less of yourself
it's thinking of yourself less
and so both of those have you know one
is actively saying you you increase your
regard for other people the other one is
just like not making yourself the center
of the universe and so those are kind of
like the mental frames that I try and
think through uh to try and decrease my
ego in the moment the third frame that I
use is the grandfather frame which I
don't know if you follow any of my stuff
but
um is thinking if I were 85 years old
and I were born into this moment like I
went through a time machine like my 85
year old self and he reimagined like he
re-emerged in this body but it's 85
years old looking at you
that man doesn't have that much ego and
he's just very grateful
to be here you know what I mean like I
wouldn't be like can you believe this
I'm here I remember when Jack looked so
young you know what I mean and Graham
like you don't be like it's actually if
you really get into that state like you
like it really shifts how you see the
world and I think the reason that ego is
so Insidious is that you can't be
grateful and have an ego
because the moment that the ego flares
you believe you deserve it
which means you can't be grateful for it
so you can't be both grateful and have
an ego which is why I think gratitude's
been so difficult for me in my life
because I it's been like of course this
happened I would expect this to happen
which also removes a lot of the Joy from
anything and so it's been something that
I've worked a lot on and I don't think
that there's a solution to it I think
it's just like the consistent chiseling
away you know layer by layer of it and
trying to remind myself that like you
know my World Views like when I die
nothing happens and I am not as
significant as I like to pretend to be
now what's wrong with feeling like you
deserve something
it's an expectation that you're placing
on reality that you can't control let's
say someone works really hard for 20
years and they you know save up money
and they say I deserve that Corvette and
they buy it is that is that a negative
that they felt like that was the
expected outcome I think if they didn't
think they deserve the Corvette and then
bought it they'd be more grateful for it
I think there's also a difference
between deserving and earning something
important to delineate between maybe you
know yeah this is why definitions are
really important this is what I jam on
but um I mean I said on the first
podcast like does that like this is a
quote from Naval who quoted somebody
else but it's you know desires a
contract we make with ourselves to be
unhappy until we get what we want and so
when we say I deserve that you're making
a statement that I unless I get this
it's like making an if then statement
for being a discontent or you know not
happy and so
I I try to avoid those at all costs
because then if your expectation is zero
of reality everything above zero is
positive
but it's just like making no making no
demands of the universe
because um shoot I think it's Albert
Ellis who said he
he interviewed zillions and zillions of
people for therapy stuff and he
continued he had like nine nine um what
did he call him he called him
I want to say disillusions distortions
there you see there's nine distortions
of reality and then there were seven and
then finally there were three and then
it stuck with three and they died right
and it was um people make demands of the
universe so it's like a circumstance
like it has to be you know sunny
tomorrow because it's my wedding it's
demand of the universe just circumstance
they make domains of other people like
people must comply with my requests they
must do things the way I want them to do
them or else they're threats right and
then finally
um there's avoidance at the bottom which
is that they will avoid like taking
accountability for their current state
through fear Etc and so
I try to avoid all three of those things
um when I'm thinking about like how I
interact with reality and so that's why
from the deserving perspective I I don't
like that language I actually actually
hate the word deserve like I deserve
this yeah I mean it's literally setting
yourself up to be angry see part of me
thinks that people deserve to be happy
they deserve to be fulfilled they
deserve a lot of things and I think
having that feeling enables them to
pursue that
otherwise if they feel undeserving of
something that may be more likely to
self-sabotage or not pursue or leave
things on the table that they could have
otherwise obtained yeah I think there's
just underlying shoulds that I just
don't agree with okay not that I think
that they're good or bad I just like I
don't think that
I don't think people deserve anything
I think we're just people period we are
what we are if we get things cool but
like I just don't think anyone deserves
anything myself included sure I'd prefer
things but I don't deserve them
this is how I see reality as far as
being grateful that's something that I
definitely used to not be very good at
and recently I've gotten a lot better at
for the past three or four months what I
do every morning as I write down don't
type it but I write down three things
I'm grateful for and it's helped you
know it's a simple exercise but now I
like to think I'm pretty good at
practicing gratitude so just a tip case
of beer in case be curious
I want to get your honest thought about
a situation that I'm going through right
now yeah FTX has been a sponsor of my
channel yeah I was curious how you were
taking that yeah horrible yeah for the
last seven months it has been
made me question every I mean I won't go
into the details but it has been
probably one of the one of the worst
weeks that I could imagine worse than
any breakup I mean I feel like I've done
so much to to just offer value and then
this happens and yeah it's it's been
shocking to see how quickly people have
turned
um and a lot of them when I really get
into it it's you know when I think
objectively about I'm like okay you know
a video gets 300 000 views got 2500
comments so there's 25 dude 2 000 are
negative and when you think it's like
okay that's that's point five percent of
the overall audience
um everyone has their own demand and
expectation from me of how I should
handle these the situation yeah and it's
it's frustrating because I I have my own
intuition of just what I would like to
do yeah and I worry that's reactionary
that that I'm only reacting because of
this and then I've I've seen other
people who are in the same situation as
me you stop sponsoring them
so I mean the hardest thing I guess for
me has been that people have come at
least I feel like people I've completely
ruined the trust I had built with my
audience over six years like my entire
life has been this yeah and it's gone
from something that I had
no idea about and it's been really tough
to deal with that and not know how to
properly address it I know how how I
would like to make the situation right
but doing that properly in a way that's
not reactionary people seem to have the
assumption that I knew what was going to
happen or like you know I was scamming
and Shilling and
um I want to get your take on it from
someone who's not in it who could think
objectively who's familiar with it
because there's the side of
you know from a business perspective you
do not address it you keep going but
then there's
a different aspect of like hey this is
PR social media I built my business on
me yeah it's not like I am the business
it's not yeah the the big statement is
brand over everything
in my opinion because like what you just
said like trust is what you've built
your entire reputation on I don't think
it's as bad as you think it is just
being on the outside okay because I
think anyone who's reasonable like if
people on Wall Street lost millions and
billions of dollars here like they were
doing they were putting a tremendous
amount of effort behind hiding you know
what they were doing yeah and so anyone
who I think is the type of person that
you would want to be associated with
your brand there's the emotions of the
situation someone might have bought many
people might have started to use FTX
because of you but whether they hold you
accountable for what happened is kind of
separate and so I think that if you kind
of like charge the shooter in terms of
saying like
I feel terrible like I lean towards
owning everything and just being like
this is the relationship that I had with
I'm sure I didn't watch the video that
you made but it's like this was the
relationship that I had with them they
were a sponsor for my videos something
felt weird so I took it off I've built
this brand off of not showing anything
really believing in products like
so-and-so said they were the JP Morgan I
thought they were the most reputable
brand believe me I get Brands every day
who try and ask me to do stuff and I
don't do it because I value y'all's
trust like I would never for the money
that I got from this I could have
equally just done something else like
you know what I mean and just very clear
like and this has been terrible for me
like imagine everything that you've
built for six years
you know gets called into question
because if honestly just a mistake you
know what I mean and and I think that
the more you just own that Narrative of
like this is this is my fault I should
have looked even closer but at the same
time like
and I think you have to speak to them
yeah they feel like how are they feeling
right now those people I'm confused
because
um when I made the first video it was a
two minute quick right to the point no
fluff no nothing okay
um and it was really well received
someone else coffeezilla made a whole
video immediately I got thousands of
people just flooding everything when I
looked through comments I do a search to
see if they've commented before on the
Channel I want to say 95 have never
commented before on the channel so you
already made a two minute video
addressing this entire matter yes what
did you say just so I know uh I said
that ftex.com was experiencing Financial
issues FTX us is separate from that and
right now is open for withdrawals yeah I
said I cut my relationship with FTX I
would recommend you take your money out
of FTX us
um I don't know right now they're
working and they claim they're separate
I don't know if I believe that so I take
your money out what you still can
um and then I just made a little mention
that you know this is a a sponsor who I
I took them at their word I was mistaken
I'm sorry for doing this or I'm sorry
that uh I basically I apologize it was a
mistake
um and you know I'm hope I'm wrong and
this whole thing resolves itself but in
case it's not then take your money I
mean that was two minutes just saying
that if you covered the core like and
you were early on it which is great like
really good and you were like hey take
it out like I and it was also before
like that shows you're protecting your
like you're fortunate in that you didn't
have to wait for everything to collapse
before doing something like was there
brand damage yes is it permanent no
do it people who are reasonable who
followed your stuff especially because
you made the two minute video beforehand
think that you were a shell no because
they've been following your stuff
forever and you're so particular and I
also know you that you're so particular
about what you enjoy like literally the
whole conversation we just had about the
the stages and who you stand next to in
the association's like we're so
particular about that because we know
how much it matters and it's just one of
those like it sucks
and it will happen and life will move on
and when you're 85 you'll be like yeah I
remember when that happened that sucked
but like it's not going to destroy your
brand I think the fact that you came
forward did it first told your people to
take it out like because you were just
not even you didn't even wait for you're
like I'm just not even sure and that's
enough for me to say I cut my
relationship with them and I told you to
take your money out like dude I think
you've done right by your audience I
don't know I I feel like the
long-standing audience does deserve
something maybe more but they want the
whole story like here's what I did
here's the research I did but I don't
know also if those are those are people
who just want to they thrive on that
sort of drama I think if you feel like
there are things that are unsaid that
you feel should be shared then share
those if you if you feel like that first
video covered all the points then yeah I
feel like a lot of it would just be but
defending myself and that that's where I
feel like I'm at
um just based on the comments and then
of course I feel like some of that you
know even if if a person never thought
of that before
uh Graham was scamming his audience or
he knew they see comments about they're
like wait a second maybe maybe these
people are right uh yeah yeah he was
scamming his audience yeah and then that
it I believe it's infectious the other
aspect is that a lot of people want to
know how much did you make from the deal
and then to give it all away and I have
no problem giving it all away not
profiting if I can if I can just count
on this with like you you want to give
the money away because you want to feel
better yes like just being real yeah I
don't think any less of your character
because you had FTX as a sponsor it
could have been coinbase it would like
to make those decisions all the time it
just happened to not work out yeah like
is there something realistically that
you can add to the process for future
sponsors oh yeah I mean I just stay away
from crypto sure like then add that you
know what I mean by all means but there
was a crypto craze and a lot of people
were like it's the new money well that's
why I thought it brokerage not any coins
or anything like that you know you're
trying to do the most like yeah you've
always made the pro brand decision and
you made it then and you made it early
the moment you sniffed something you
didn't keep taking their money like if
you had at that point like right when
you were like things are weird I'm gonna
take the next check yeah you know esop's
Fable of the man the boy in the mule no
I think it's useful to know okay so this
is like a multi-thousand year old story
so there's a father a son and a mule and
they're walking right and all three of
them are walking and then people walk by
and they're like what a waste of a mule
they're like why would you have a mule
walking when you've got you know two
people walking beside it so the father
puts his son on the on the mule and they
keep walking and the next group of
people come by and they're like
what a terrible boy making his old
father walk next to him while he rides
the mule so they hear that and then the
kid gets off and the father gets on and
they're riding and the next group of
people pass by and they're like what a
terrible father making his son walk next
to him while he walks while he rides the
mule and so as they walk as they get
into town
they uh they they Hop Off The Mule they
take a stick and then they tie the
donkey's feet together and then they put
the stick over the shoulder and then
they start carrying the mule
um
and the moral of the story is like all
four of the scenarios are the four
possibilities they could have done and
off and then of course people there
saying they're idiots too and so it's
like you can't please everyone
and so it's like you can only do the
thing that you know is right and you're
the only one who has context on your
situation no one else does the funny
thing is that when we die the only
person who has full context on our
scenario dies with us
and so like you're the judge yeah so if
you feel good I'm like rock if you're
like I feel weird then it's like then
get that handled and then be twice as
loud
because you shouldn't have anything to
be ashamed of thank you yeah no worries
thank you appreciate it guys we really
appreciate you coming on so yeah hope
you enjoyed yeah hope we get some of
them Clippy clippies